This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company to
provide free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina,
this is it. Here we go. We're finally
here. I can finally do it, gene. Okay,
the second half.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah, I liked it. I have been
wanting to announce these dates,
but take it down world
tour. Oh Shit, homie.
Turn it down.
Turn it down to headphones.
Tommy's and turn that shit
down and headphones. Dude,
I'm so stoked. All right.
It's finally here.
People have been asking me about
different cities and now I can tell you,
I can tell you,
go ahead.
Coming to a bunch of cities,
all the cities I've been asked about,
I'm coming dog,
Minneapolis. Whoa. LA, Denver,
Toronto, Vancouver, Miami,
Austin, Phoenix, Miami,
Homie, the UK up comments. I Londontown
had a practice. Your accent.
Hello? I'm coming to Europe.
I'm doing European dates.
Can you announce that there's a
whole bunch of them. I don't mind.
Into my motherland. Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can you say that? And I don't want to,
I don't want to take out one of my what
and make sure you go to the site. Okay,
I'll go to Tom segura.com/tour.
Now,
here is the thing that happens when
you listen to this podcast right now.
The uh,
the general on sale starts
Friday the 12th. Okay.
But you're listening or watching right
now. If you're listening on the ninth,
if you're watching on the 10th and
the 11th, the answer hasn't started.
You can use my code. Oh, champ. Okay.
C h a m p champ and that will unlock the,
uh,
the tickets so you can
actually get tickets before
the rest of the public does.
Thank you everybody who signed up on the
email as you got that email yesterday.
Um, that's it, man.
That's the tour continues.
It's going to be all over North
America, all over Canada, Europe,
and there's even going to be another
announcement in a few months about another
one other market. You are just tearing
up the world this year. Jeans. I know.
It's pretty crazy. I'm so excited.
I'm excited for this European leg.
I'm super excited to European league.
We have so many.
Mommy's in the UK are going to be so
excited too,
so I appreciate everybody.
A lot of you guys would hit me
up about a UK for a long time,
so I'm very excited about, no, Tom
Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
He used the code word champ.
Gene. Uh, personality champ.
That's me. Water Champ. That's me.
I would like to thank everybody.
Could came out too many apple tits.
The acme comedy club.
What a great weekend that was.
So the ride or die tour or roles right
along May 10th and 11th now I will be in
Tempe,
Arizona at the Tempe Improv May 31st
through June 1st sperm bank here at the
flappers comedy club June 20th I want
to actually flappers comedy club.
I am not, I don't speak your
language. Nurses Burbank.
Sorry. You're right. You're right. Yeah.
That's Burbank,
California as the flappers comedy.
I don't know where the fuck that is.
This takes and out of her mind.
June 20th through 22nd Washington,
Dick Com,
Washington DC at the DC improv
tickets or at Christina P on line.
Also, if you're new to me you need to the
podcast, check out my Netflix specials.
I've an hour called mother inferior under
Christina P is my name there and the
degenerates half hour.
When I was eight months pregnant with
our second child and I told filthy come
Dick Jokes, he must pregnant. That's nice.
Tee shirts for the ride or
die tour available. Uh, Tom
Sugar is merged. Paid. Yes.
Go to merge method.com/time very excited
that the everybody can be a water champ
cause we have water jug water bottle.
You don't have to drink water to
be considered a water champ. Tom.
What up now I've got to go for your
one merchbee.com/thomas to grow.
And what I'm very very
excited about is um,
I don't know if we have it in the show.
Do you have that drew clip in the
show or no? Do you have that video?
Oh Dude, we can just play it in a minute.
We'll just open the show cause it's too,
it's too much fun. I'm loving the water
champ bottle. I have one at the house.
I use it around the house.
What's great about it is that it doesn't
have a tinny tastes the way a lot of
water bottles often do. And I love
the top, the Sippy Cup, the sippy top.
I don't know what the fuck those were
calling either, but it's so easy.
It's a great size. Great to
represent the show. Take it to the,
to the work. To the office. Take it to
the gym, take it to the Gen Tate outside.
God. But that on your
tool belt. That's right.
All right. Should we start the show? Gene,
let's get into this. Let's get into this.
Shows me my gosh.
What is your mom doing?
Don't bring anyone. Mothers. No, no,
no.
Go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay.
There's a, it's, it's British. Christina,
what am I talking about here?
I think you're upset.
You didn't get tickets to the take
it down to her. Oh, is that right?
Fucking
fucking,
what was that last bit?
Master of accents?
David Bowie.
Yeah.
Amen.
And there's something about it.
Oh, let's do something about it.
I'm fucking fuming.
Tears come out of it. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jesus. I was very upset to this day.
How did you find this one?
Ah,
someone sent it to me saying that
this was Christina from the future.
I wasn't sure, but I mean, I kind of
see, I see. The reason I kind of do too,
actually, if I'm being honest. Yeah. I,
I don't not see a resemblance.
Right?
Like if I were to gain
a good other fifth day,
those are my old teeth.
Those are teeth I had when I was a kid.
The space and then that
bulging eyes. Easy. Yeah. Easy.
If you had stayed after your semester
or your year at my hair. Yep. Yep.
This could have been Mississippi.
Be you eating those sandwiches.
You love curry chicken, mango
chicken man Chutney. This bitch, man.
I know it's not, it doesn't not, not
look like me. I'm not going to lie.
This would make, it could be my
Dick invert grow into my body.
What are you talking about?
If this was like what?
I woke up and saw in the
morning, I'd be like, Bib.
Nobody wakes up next to this woman.
Someone does know that's
a celibate man now. Yeah.
Now you gotta maintain bro as you can
keep going. I don't know. That's it.
Thank God. Oh, what is she
so upset? She stress me out.
It's possibly about the weather
soaking wet.
Yeah.
Maybe she's talking about her panties
though. Awesome. She's getting turned on.
I am referring to the weather.
So this is your confirming this
every day for months and months.
I'm going to do my whole
set with a British actor.
When you do it like a pirate
from pirates of the Caribbean,
like a fake British Pirate
Crocodile Dundee.
I know the difference.
You don't know you're doing your
British accent like Crocodile Dundee.
Do it again.
I bet you were invited to London
was you didn't just show up.
Demand this to invitation only.
Bitch. Hashtag invitation.
Invitation only. Yeah. We keep
a strict code around here.
Not just anybody can get on a
bit of a Wyffels. Not
a fucking phrase. It.
Bob's your uncle in British town.
Got All, what was your uncle and
you know
what?
Put it this way,
at the end of sentences,
it's a little more proper.
You know London, isn't it? Cockney
bangers and mash. I love it. I could,
I could live there. You know what?
You're going to love their bro.
Real talk.
English breakfast is kind of the
fucking jail I remember. Yeah,
I remember last summer I was
in London and it's so long ago,
but I was there with you also.
Peter's invited wrestle and is a little
place called the o two arena. Can you,
can you even believe that you did that?
I think about you doing that.
And we went to Bam.
We did London though too.
And it was crazy. And he was to
10,000 how many people each show?
I was shitting my pants for you and,
and Russell would go up there anyway,
so it was like, no. First we did a
tuneup, his warmup show unreal was in,
I guess it was in Birmingham, right? Or
was it, yeah, it wasn't Birmingham. Yeah.
Were we went to Birmingham.
He's like,
we do a up show before the arena show.
I hadn't even been in an arena and the
warm up show in Birmingham was 7,000
people. So he was just like, he's
kind of get, you know, get loose.
See what it's like here. I bombed on
that show. I ate shit and Birmingham,
you're a lot harder on yourself
because I remembered that didn't go.
You did not bomb. I didn't bomb bomb,
but I was like, Huh. And he actually,
we were talking after the show. I was
like, uh, yeah. I remember I was like,
is that there wasn't great.
And they're like,
that's because this is what even he said,
he goes,
those people were off the boat like he's
like here that you did it show tough
foreigners.
But in London it was a little
more like art contemporaries. Yes.
I remember it was such a unique experience
of Russell Peters Shell because you
look down,
you look at the audience
and it was just a sea of,
yeah, it was my step. Dad put it that way.
My step dad and his family and
it was right, there was a huge,
the Birmingham show,
he was like,
these people just got
here and then London.
It was like,
what?
You'd expect a mix of everything
to the culture and any reference,
but the shows when really
differently, very differently. I mean,
I couldn't imagine being,
I don't even know how far along comedy.
Where are you at that point in
your career? Uh, seven, eight.
I remember I was shitting nervous for
you and watching you up on these huge
monitors and I was like,
how is he doing this right now?
I was just so impressed that you could
even have the nerve to die. I couldn't.
We showed her two weeks later I
did a comedy central presents.
Isn't that crazy work? Yeah.
Wow. With a full charge. Right?
Wasn't he charged Jay Larson.
Wow. Taped or special? Very cool.
I remember that when, when
I was in London, I was like,
man, we're pretty close
to broke. Oh yeah. And uh,
Russell, I didn't tell him.
I was like, man, but he, um,
he had his personal wire, the payment
to us. I was like, oh we can pay our,
I remember that he was so generous
and kind. He flew both of us out,
put us up in a hotel, fed us, I mean,
and his wonderful brother
Clayton and his wife.
And it was just wonderful trip.
It was a wonderful trip.
I'll always be grateful to Russell
Peters because he kept us alive for a few
years. Yeah. There's a few people, right.
And so many people have that story by the
way. Oh, I know. Oh Russell. Well yeah,
we'll have a guest come I think. I don't
know if it aired. Yeah. George Perez,
Russell. Peter Stories.
Well, very generous.
And I've met like 10 other guys
who have a story like that. Yeah.
A lot of people have a Russell
stories. Sweet guy, sweet family.
So we were at the country club,
it the mall and um,
I've decided as a married person,
cause we've been together for 15 years.
Um, I'm just going to start
letting you pick out my clothes.
You introduced that whole concept to
me. Yeah. I never thought that way.
You were like, you should pick things.
And I go, why you? Because you look at me.
Yeah.
I don't look at me.
You look at me and I should just
start taking you shopping as well.
I'm talking about how I'd
never do that though. I do.
I try to get you to approve
things. Yeah, but I was so we went,
I went dress shopping
with you and I was like,
just go pick some stuff
that you want to see me in.
And of course she brought
back the shortest,
lowest cut hoochie stuff.
My teds were coming out of every dress. I
was like, man, I got these monster Ted's,
they don't fit.
And like cute little girl.
I'm a grown ass woman and you don't
want to see what we got about to shoot a
scene.
Keep those tits in that dress.
But there has to be a of raw.
Ah, what? What's the theme?
What's your fantasy? Oh,
you're like, oh, it was,
I hope you try it on in the dressing
room. Sure. Yeah. What don't we do that?
Let's go back to the mall right
now. Yeah, you're backed up.
You are so nasty. What'd I say to you?
I was like, when I go out tonight,
you got to jerk it. Yeah, I can see
that. The phone's ringing. I go,
I got my,
I got to the comedy store tonight.
I can't make sweet marital loves to
you tonight cause I'm working. I said,
when I'm gone, I want you
to clean your pipes. Yeah.
And what did you tell me you're
going to do with your pipe sauce?
I said I was going to check
off on your pillow so that you,
when you get back home, you lay down.
It's just like, what are you five?
You sit up, you're like, what's going
on in your pillows? Stuck to your head.
Are you listening to that? To Matt?
Hello? Slowly just falls off. You're like,
what is that? It's nine. He talked
to your lady. That's how it turned.
Tricks on what checks.
That's what chicks like.
Chicks don't like this kind of talk.
Yeah, they do. Listen, I'm damaged goods.
That's why I tolerate this kind of
tall. I got trauma. Childhood issues.
No normal woman. No normal woman
will put up with this. No, no man,
no, you got me. You got me at
a vulnerable point. I was like,
like a wounded, uh, what's the word?
Gazelle snatched me right up before I got
into therapy. You know, I like you. I,
I love you. I love you. Are you
anyways, I taught her three year old
son. How to say I need to take a dump.
And you've not been
happy with I don't think.
I mean cause obviously I think
that's funny, but you know it's good.
There's context and like then you have
our little boy in situations like,
you know, looking like the animal. I
just don't want him to, you know, to be,
to say it to somebody and then
they're like, that's really cool that,
well listen, I need to take it
down. But it isn't dirty. It's not,
it's not little kids. I gotta
make a poo poo. Poos dumb, boring.
I know. But these three, man, what
about Brown? Can we compromise?
Can I teach him to say I need to make
a brown? Yeah, I think that's okay.
I mean dump has a little funnier.
It's funny here. It is funny here,
but we're not shooting
up, you know, a video.
It's what's the point of
having to comedian parents
if it's not going to be fun
for you. All right. You
know what I mean? Okay.
He's going to be saying that
people are gonna be like, Hey,
you know something really ha today.
It wasn't very nice.
Your son announced he had to take a dump.
He refused upon on his pull ups
the other day at school. Yeah.
And I was like a free ball and dude.
And he was like, yeah, good for him.
That's what he wants. I like that. I like
a little rebelliousness. It's good. Okay.
Well, healthy distrust of
authority. I gotta take a dump.
So one day I was like, excuse
me? He's like, I take a dump.
And I was like, okay. Yeah. And I noticed,
don't think I didn't notice this morning.
I got out of the shower and it was
fucking so cold and around like,
I'm happy you are.
And then I check the thermostat.
You had it down to 68 degrees.
It felt good. It felt nice.
How old man? By the way, you fall, you
always fall asleep before me last night.
I don't know if you do this in
the middle of the, of your sleep,
you kicked your blankets off, you
know? No, I did. Yes you did. No Way.
Yes you did. That's you then you're
just, that's propaganda. Nah,
it's not propaganda. You kicked it off
and did determine NAC on yeah, of course.
And we were hot both. I was like, I'm hot.
And then I look at you and you're like
obviously telling me that you're hot.
I'm not hot. Yeah, you
were hot. You were hot
blue man. Just but Hashtag Thermostat,
gate, Thermostat, gate. Yeah.
Go ahead and tweet me.
Let me know what your ideal temp
is in spring time. [inaudible] um,
I like a 76.
That is where I am.
And then in winter and the spring I like
it to be 76 actually all the all times.
Um, let me know what your ideal temp is.
Ladies. There's no way anyone's like you.
No one said,
oh one six man,
she had it 78 for a while. She's like,
it feels good. It does feel good.
It's nor doesn't feel good. And
look, everyone's shaking their hand.
Well Blue Band. What do you
keep your nest at? 69 baby
about Chris 72.
Now we know that it's in my lane.
I,
Josh can't weigh in cause he's severe
disturbs the cockroach and he's like 45
feels nice
by the way.
Did you guys battle it out
of over who got the, uh, the,
the ball kick the ball mate?
I mean, we haven't discussed
it yet, but I know, uh,
you know he has a Greek genes in them and
I can see his chest hair coming out of
his shirt sometimes. Yeah. Oh, okay.
Maybe Chris wants them to Chris. Oh,
Chris barely asked some hair.
Oh,
but this isn't going to be for the arms.
Can we do it?
Can we have some type of contest where
you guys battle it out? You know? Oh Shit.
Yeah. What would be the parameters? All
shaving. Yeah. That's a really nice kit.
It is a really nice kit from
manscaped. How about pushups? Pushups.
Oh,
he's walking.
Oh my God. Jesus just walked
on our set. I didn't even know
your bombs. That was we'll be
right. Yes, right around the pipe.
But that valley, sometimes I get to
the page, so I got the trim. The hair,
the tape split ends. Yeah. I
take this bullet in his arm.
I just leave like a little Bush.
Just role and then you fucking uh,
yeah. We're going to dig. It looks
good. My girls don't get handled.
I've never seen my balls don't get no.
Hey,
I get like a wall strand from time that
Trump. Are you Harry on your chest? No,
I have no hair on your
butt. Your cooler. Oh No.
You don't have a Harry Potter
Hall? No, I go, that's nice.
Sometimes the time you get that wild
hair that grows out and you just pluck it
out. I got a forest back there
in your asshole. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. No, no, no. I'm not a,
sometimes I shit hair.
Would they call lumping young Cuban?
What's that called? Lumpy you.
You don't have a lot of hair.
I have hairy legs, dude. You know I did a
Spanish set a few weeks ago. All Spanish.
How'd you, how'd it go? It went
well. It went well. I had a fun time.
It was Marvin for that.
I go to Miami,
I'm going to add a second show on
Thursday and just try a Spanglish show.
Really? Yeah. Just Spanglish. Went up
a little, you know, she'll Cuban isms.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause the Cuba is very
funny. Yeah. It adds a very funny,
uh, whatever and all have to
do is go up there and play.
And one of my relatives yeah.
With that broken English and they know it.
Fucking hilarious. Yeah. And my hands
are great for that. You did that span.
You did, uh, your, I think it was your
stepfather or your uncle and your,
this is not happening, right.
What happened? What happened
here? What happened here?
What happened? What happened? Yeah. And he
would try the same all the fucker. Yeah.
That's all he knew. Yeah. That's
all he knew. And I love the,
the detail of like when, uh,
what he could say that to you,
but like if the cops come and he's like,
no, nobody knows English, you know,
they played that.
So what is so fun and they played it.
It's hilarious at this. I should take
risk. Are you ready for this? Yeah,
that my mother would come home at night.
She'd go,
listen tomorrow he can't go to school
equals and we give you a hundred bucks.
Go to de Luca with them.
Look was an attorney and the
neighborhood fucking deadly Jew deadly.
He represented you.
You got Scott off like I know people,
you know the Sullivan
Act Now the Sullivan Act,
those when you get pulled over
with a piece in New York City,
you just go straight to jail.
You do a year say, oh right,
don't fucking worry you
are a half whatever dog.
I still want him to get people
off of that. Off of gun charges.
He had a menu like when you went to
see him and go, okay, sit down Tom.
Nice to see Christina is the situation.
They caught you with this.
They got you on the phone.
I can make the tapes disappear and I can
get to the judge that's going to cost
you 400,000 for 300,000 the
tape will be admissible,
but Ohio, an FBI witness to say
that they were tampered with.
You're still going to do six
months, but 200,000 he, dude,
nine months and 400,000 you got
to do 18 months. Give me a call,
think about it.
Great to see.
And it would be like a re wrote
my mom and step out and be like,
at what anybody else would be like,
okay, Lisa, you don't even know.
They knew what he was saying. Right. They
would never let the cat out of the bag.
They, yeah, they played immigrants.
Keep that leverage. However you got
to keep your of jury duty too. Yeah.
It's a Hungarian community trick.
My Dad,
I said once I get the thing Songolo
talk, Manto, Donald, thank you.
Just go in and you're like,
oh, you want to hear it?
These poor bastards,
these poor white basses and Hollywood
doggedly had thrown under the jail. Yeah.
For paying off their fucking kids college.
Yeah.
Nala bail.
They're going to get thrown under the
jail and the two 50 she's going to get
some probation.
We'll listen.
I kidnapped the Dude Ruhlmann a trunk
of a car and my bail was 50,000 yeah,
it's always paid $1 million,
a million dollar bail a piece
and the next day when they,
when you went to use their ATM
card, it was like, it's an good,
what are you talking about? No good.
I just put a half a mil in that.
No you didn't. No you didn't. The
feds get on that shit over there.
They don't even fuck around those
people sucking Dick Right now.
Full House check tripping
in the valley right now.
That's a half of la racketeering.
They just seize your assets. Yeah.
They wait to you come from trial,
which and then they just take everyday.
It's wild. May Go to your house
the next day with tape recorders.
Crazy that they felt so
compelled like that there
kid could just go in there, kick it.
We've got a gotten to any college,
but they're like, no, my
kid's going to go here
guys.
I do not want my child involved
in any aspect of this area.
I am just waiting for a signal
to get the fuck outta here.
Whether it's a little out of Reno,
maybe it's Vegas,
maybe it's time to see and it's because
of what's happened in the last three
years.
Harvey Weinstein,
Jesse Small at uh,
you know our Kelly,
you've got to think of this
Michael Jackson documentary.
You just saw this thing
with these fucking people.
Pay for your kids to go to college.
It's a bad environment.
Just think of this is all
the Hollywood machine. Yeah.
If you really think of Jesse's son
a lot, I feel bad for him. Yeah.
I feel bad for him because
he got sucked into it.
Have you ever been on a set and you see
people getting sucked into it and then
one day you come out of that fog between
the business manager of the agent,
this manager,
you're 19th assistance.
You're fucking broke now we go
on the road because we enjoy it.
I don't go on the road for money. I go on
the road cause I'm a good fucking time.
When you go on the road for money because
you need to pay the mortgage and yeah,
that's, that's, that's not that much fun.
Taking pictures with
people and hanging out.
It's not so the point I was getting to us,
they're so stupid. She looking
at me, you're like, man,
I'm not the most intelligent guy
I got into University of Colorado.
No high school diploma. Really? Oh yeah.
I just kept telling them I'll
send them next week after week.
Every time they bump into me, the
counselor was your high school diploma.
Next week it's coming
overnight, mail, Fedex.
Then I went to continuing Ed,
which is an extension of the University
of Colorado and you go there first for
awhile and then when you get enough
credits you transfer into the,
I got the letter, you get you to
go to shit or get off the pot.
You got to transform it. This is
true story. I went down there,
I got the application,
35 bucks.
I just made up a bunch of fucking shit
because I had taken classes at Colorado
Mountain college and Aspen and all
those credits transferred with me.
That's not when you launched. Correct.
They didn't used to lose credits that,
you know when you transfer that
might need to cry. Fuck you.
I'm not losing. I did. I did
fucking residential wiring.
I did all these fucking classes.
So they didn't take those credits in me.
The university came to me,
came to my face.
I don't give a fuck who goes to jail now.
And they were like,
I wasn't thinking Tom. Yeah.
I used the application.
Joey Diaz.
I wasn't even thinking about it.
A week later denied.
But when I went to one of the classes,
I bumped into a guy that was trying to
help me and he goes, aren't you Cuban?
And I go, yeah. He goes,
what's your real name? I go,
Jose.
And the guy looked at me and he goes,
if you were to re do your paperwork,
staple your birth certificate on them.
Jose Diaz,
let's see what happens.
Let me put a word in for you though.
The application wasn't even dry.
I dropped it off.
And by the time I got home at the time
I had a pager, but I had a home number.
Yeah, and they had already left a
message. I, Jose, congratulations.
You've been accepted to Colorado,
listened to them.
I'm snorting coke with three
hands. I'm about to go to
prison. I go, no, no, not yet.
I hadn't kidnapped the guy yet,
so I'm taking clam selling cars,
not in cold.
I'm hanging out in the fucking see you
weight room with Michael Pritchard,
nor the football players that
teach me how to tape ankles.
I'm lifting weights with them. I'm
happy. I'm living like a double light.
I'm selling cars,
robbing people,
snorting blow at 90 plus c and then the
date time at from like five to nine I
became a fucking fag.
He students,
I had my little shirt on him and I
go take classes and talk to people.
I was studying political science because
once they came at me with that program,
but it was called to see you, Oop,
college program. Are you ready for this?
All you had to do was maintain a c
plus and they kept giving you money.
I had become Joey cash registers because
I had a friend that Halloween fresh,
he had a book for all the money
they gave Spanish people. See,
this is all those fucking
dumb white people.
All they had to do was go to the border.
As soon as the Mexican jumps the wall,
they grabbed my key. Listen, no program
or we're going to take it to her house.
You're going to marry my
stupid white daughter.
You're going to have like a fake
wedding, Guadalajara style, whatever.
I'm going to give you 10 g's set. You
think about the half milk, half million.
They paid half of them.
They could have paid twenty thousand
thirty thousand married the daughter and
now you're not Christina presents no more.
You're Christina Hernandez and
you walk right into fucking
fucking stupid. How easy, how many
loopholes you see the girl yesterday,
the dumb bitch didn't even play fucking
soccer. Now did you say this? No.
Yesterday the chip soccer,
they went to the soccer coach
and he said you couldn't make,
this is one of the daughters.
Yeah. Yesterday. Yesterday.
It came out that the guy took a chick from
around here somewhere, woodland hills,
and they fucking made a fake profile that
she was a soccer player and then made
the captain,
the chicken ever fucking kicked the ball.
The coach was like,
I never saw her.
So it's rocket theory was they got
the soccer coach at Ucla or USC?
Correct me if I'm alone.
Racketeering.
I mean it's just cold blooded and they
didn't need to go to Lowe's or treatment.
Yeah. Why would you have to go
to these extremes and doing this?
You know how much money they
would give him? Literally,
every time I turn my head,
I was getting that check for
25 of 100 to 5,000 Jose Marti,
Johnny, and he's a Spanish
guy that made more money.
They just don't donate and they have a
fun to sit in for Spanish people and all
you gotta do is just applying.
They would give me fucking down and you're
like, I don't know. I look nice. No, no,
no. I wouldn't talk on this. And when
I was on campus, I was like a Jap.
You know how jabs come around
with a camera and they buy
nothing. I ain't, no, no.
I don't know. You should've seen
me. You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying? I wasn't
the fat chicken and uh, and man,
I'm fired when the heat log with
Nina La Nina. They would talk
to me. I didn't know nothing.
I bow like a fucking,
like I just came back from Cuba.
You should've seen me from why. As soon
as I hit the fucking campus, I was like,
oh,
I was like a half a retard
and I kept asking even though I was like
that retarded kid that has to follow
everybody in school.
I get to school everyday because
he forgets what the school is.
You've had that got to just
tag along. He's just waiting
for you. I was like, Gosh,
Shit.
I held that fucking Monica for two years
and when I would see people from the
college, I'd just be
shut. Sorry, what's that?
I said, oh my God. It
was fucking hilarious.
When I was shocked.
When they find my paperwork,
they're going to put me under the
jail with those dumb white people.
Cause I think more money.
I was taking money in prison
when I came out of prison,
the first place I went to him,
and this is where it is in Colorado,
they had like three checks waiting for
me, but like 12, five, that's how I got,
you know, not in the Mafia. They give
you a boost. They gave me a boost,
they gave me a 12 five boosts and then
when I reapplied they said you can't come
into the University of Colorado said
felonies. Oh really? So now they had me.
So I had to switch majors from political
science because this is going to hire
me as an attorney.
My plan was to get a coal plant,
political history, history, major
political science, history manager,
and then get into the Spanish
law school like a doctor.
And that's where the big money came.
That's when they started buying your
cars and paying for your apartment.
And let me tell you something.
Uh, about four years ago,
I got a letter in the mail from
the US State Department. They Shit,
me and my wife looked at it.
We hit the drum roll and we opened it up.
All they wanted back was 2,600 bucks.
Are you serious?
Out of the hall that they ain't
and they wanted it back though?
26 25 a student loan.
I had to take it out for 2,600 for
12 credits or something like that.
I just took the 26 and bought
a car and then sold the car.
I was flipping cars that on campus.
Geez. It's going. I'm saying
like
this was a fucking money machine.
It was a money machine.
This is why when you're Spanish on,
you have to do is go from
where you don't want to be.
You're not going to get into USC.
They're not going to give me no money.
We got 2000 Mexicans. This
neighborhood. Yeah. You remote danger.
We go to Iowa City,
Iowa.
Anyway with blacks and
Spanish don't want to be,
because they'll look at each other and go,
why are we here?
Because we'll get Mitch,
whether it's Montana, Boise,
Boise, you know those places.
University of Michigan,
the brass and the Brassica
all they got, you know,
so that's the mood.
The mood.
What did you do when you got
out of prison to make money?
First thing like you're, I wouldn't pick
up that check with 12 five I was like,
I was like fucking Henry Hill. We got to
go to Pittsburgh tomorrow. Yeah. Yeah.
My wife's like, well you have a meeting
with your probation. There's no worry.
It's taken care of right away.
I picked up the 12 five and I got a job
selling cars cause don't let anybody
out. You could breathe in through the
bottom of the glass. Don't let yourself,
so no, no, no. The
first I could sell cars.
I'm lying to you because
I had to get my license.
You have to get your license redone.
Now my driver's license,
but my car salesman license.
So I got a job in the
halfway house detailing cars,
but I really wasn't detailing cars. I
was selling below. What I would do is,
so let's say I was coming, where do you
work? I work at Thomson grow industries.
Six, six, six months in Berlin.
I would give them the address,
but I tell them I'm a detail, we don't
hear the phone ring, so just paid me
for the page.
So why would I would be driving around,
you know I have to drive
until you're level four.
Fuck you had a car parked two
blocks away driving around town.
When that pulled up next to a
counselor at the light and I'm like,
please don't turn around please.
And she didn't turn it around and I got
away wave. And this is in Colorado still.
This is boulder,
Colorado.
I was slinging coke,
selling cars. I was clean,
but then I came up positive
from weighing the coke.
When you pick up the rocks and shit,
this shit goes through your fingers
and it goes into your bloodstream.
So I piss coke and I told him the problem
started now I had to wear gloves and a
mask. What happened when you,
when you test the positive though?
The first time they made me go to a
90 day out treatment like rd lanes.
And you went, Oh yeah, I'm in this
someone cold and get my big success.
There was a chicken,
the group that would suck the just by
looking at night he'd give us a little
break. We'd go behind the
building, a little suit,
color main because I go back
then I tell him about my mother,
how she beat me with a paper towel.
I chick's name was Patrice.
I don't forget that.
I would just see her when she sucked.
My daughter,
she was in the halfway house with me.
I would check in when you've got until
the halfway house you'd have to sign your
name and they'll always be a note come
by my door cause it was chicks on the
first floor and I would go by her door,
knock on the door,
give her a little piece of coke and
just take my dick out of the door.
Like if I was talking to,
I be hanging out like another
thing is she'd be sucking my Dick,
the counselor be on the other side.
Boom. I shoot my son Ain't good juice.
Put the helmet back in and I go upstairs
and hour later she'd be fucking join up
a stone downstairs by itself. I was
selling coke at the halfway house. Jesus.
I was loaning money. Really? I was a loan
shark. Yeah, because your rent has to be,
that's how they fuck with you.
The system fucks with you.
They know you don't get paid till Friday,
but they would make you pay your rent
on Thursday. You 75 bucks a week.
So I would lend out 75 for
one oh two I don't believe it.
Ask me where I came up with the
figure 75 for one or two on Saturday.
Let them cash that check.
Now what happens if someone
doesn't have the one or two ready?
I will fuck with them.
Yeah.
I just say go fuck yourself or you get
nothing from me. I've got three guys.
You ever stop and think?
Do you ever just stop about like thinking
about where you are now in your life,
right? You're this great comedian,
you have this beautiful family,
a beautiful daughter, and you think
about how crazy you fucking were,
like the shit you were doing. It doesn't
it seem like it's a different person.
I come to terms with it. You know that
song by the talking heads, you know,
you might ask yourself living in a shotgun
shack like that. When I look at mercy,
the Troll, I think about that
song. How did I get it? Yeah,
so to set that so I wouldn't go
to a psychiatrist or whatever.
I broke it down into three categories.
The first category was when I lived
with my mother until she died.
I was also on Tony. That's what
she called me a, I'm throwing it.
That's what my family calls me.
They don't another about cold call or Joe,
we fucking nothing.
They don't hold trying to Tonio.
And then when my mother died,
it became coco and that
was the motherfucker that
was just out of his mind.
And then when I was about
42 I became Joey Dennis.
Wow. I came to add two more
years or snorting coke,
but I was on the upswing. At least it
was like I was doing a little heroin.
I was doing coke during the week.
I would just do heroin on Mondays
and just carry over for the week.
And uh, that's how I look at it just so
I could sleep at night. Yeah. You know,
just so I could sleep at night.
There's something else amazing happened
recently that I talked to you briefly
about was that you'd always told stories
about obviously the kidnapping and,
and being locked up and getting out.
And you would jokingly talk about how you,
you sent a Facebook request to the guy
who kidnapped and he wouldn't accept it.
You're like, oh I didn't for years. For
years you would always talk about it.
He always made me laugh.
And then recently you said you
did a show and the motherfucker,
he came to your show.
I kept last last year really pissed me
off because he was supposed to come to
Tempe cause he never came Ken.
And it pissed me off.
Like I went back to the hotel room because
you don't remember when you're there.
Christina. I'm coming to your show
tomorrow night. 10 o'clock all right.
See you then.
And that was good drive on me.
Like I didn't see Joey Diaz and
somebody will go, he was there.
He just left before you got off
or something. Yeah. You know,
so he didn't show and I said that's it.
This is the fifth time he has to show.
Then I would, dear friend
of mine said, listen,
the reason why he did this show
was he hasn't forgiven himself.
Worked with Southam. Yeah.
Work with him on this.
He hasn't really come to terms
with what happened. You know,
he was no innocent bystander.
He was an deal pill.
He just got double cross like I did.
So when I went to Tucson,
I called them the week before I
said, I'm coming to Tucson. He goes,
I'm coming and I'm sitting downstairs.
I thought he didn't show and there
he was and I just hugged him.
I didn't say much cause we apologize
for each other on the phone.
I just hugged him for white three or
four minutes and it was like, Whoa,
this hugs we'll, I didn't
have to say nothing was just
the way I was hugging him.
It was like this,
I'm really sorry about that day.
I can't imagine what you went through,
you know?
I really can't imagine what you went
through. It was a great day for me.
Had a good time.
I lived out some fucking wild fantasy.
Do you think he really thought,
was he terrified for his life in that,
in that scenario? Yeah. Yeah. I
mean, you know why he didn't stop.
He got in trouble. He got stabbed in
the face like six months later. Like he,
he was on a roll. The same role I
was on. Let's get something straight.
The reason why we met someone cars,
but then he disappeared for a while.
He would get into a fight with the sales
manager and leap was very good looking,
very charismatic at the time. And he
came back in that time when he came back,
when I met him, when he came into my
life, he had a cast on like RV. Yeah.
One of those like casts and I go,
what happened? And he goes, ah,
I got chased by the cops and I
crashed into a tree and I got a Dui.
But they took me to the hospital and why?
He was in the hospital getting treated.
He broke out of the emergency room,
kicked the door down to the store pharmacy
and took every painkiller and every
bottle of liquid covad they
had jumped out the window,
three stories and ran away.
And they called them two days later.
So the reason he was in a position he
was in was because he knew where the coke
was hitting his partners.
Coke was it.
And he wanted to rob as partners
coke and sell it that mate,
do you understand this? So what
a tangle. Well, tail we, we,
when we tangled to deceive,
yeah, I had different plans.
I'm not a fucking salesman. I'm
looking to just take your fucking coke.
So that's what went that.
So he was not,
and then after I saw
when I got out of jail,
he was even more fucked up.
I bumped into him six,
seven months after I got out of jail.
I was already into comedy.
I bumped into him at a bar and he
was fucked up to the guilt. He goes,
what are you doing here? When did
you get out? I'm like, I'm sorry,
like go sell me a gram of
Makoko and never forget.
Went into the men's bathroom and
they had one of those pockets gales,
and while he was weighing the Koch, he
was fucking happened. It kept going.
I can't believe you kidnapped me. Tell
him, listen, it was a bad day. It happens.
It's a bad day and you put yourself
in a bad position. We shook hands.
We even did a blast.
The bathroom,
we went out and had a beer and then
comedy took over my life and then one day
when Facebook came along and I seen
him on there and I from requests let me
throw me to go fuck.
He wrote me like
he is shit. Then you know that secret
compartment you have in your Facebook,
there's like a messenger that you get
messages on, but you never check it.
One day I checked in, I had 2000
messages. Yeah, he was. He's like,
you got some fucking pair of
balls asking me to be your friend.
You tied me up and handcuff me and shit.
You know,
I could move my hand for three days.
I was walking around like I had a
stroke and all this shit. You're like,
can we be friends? And I'm like,
wait, listen man. You know what?
I'm sorry you feel that way. I get it. You
know, I wasn't trying to be rude to him.
I just had this sense that, listen,
let me tell you something. Hey,
he's got that step that they want you to
reach out and apologize to some people.
When the fucking Christopher Moltisanti,
he got out of the other Rehab Queens,
the Sopranos, and he thought, and Tony's
asked him, are you clean? Gann he goes,
I'm even reaching out to some people.
In some cases I sent some people money,
some people flowers because
of the biologies and,
but it looks at me because there's
some things you should leave a well,
like I've reached out to
as many people as I can.
There's some people that are
never going to get it. Yeah,
I'm not even going to try.
I even reached out to my ex
wife you did and said, listen,
that was a different person then and
then she went on this fucking diatribe
about blow up about it and I go,
you know what,
I'm not ever going to get through
to her either, but at least I tried.
I tried and the reason why she's done
that is because I've made a conscious
decision that we both
got something we wanted.
She wanted to be a mom and she
had the kid and I got to life.
So I'm like fucking then Zell and man
on fire. I gave a life, get a life,
you know, and I've come to terms
with it. You can do. Yeah, no,
I got a beautiful six year old,
I got the wife. There's no drama
and here I am fucking rainy
California right now and shit.
Two favorite people.
Every time I talked to you,
I feel like I'm about to see you like
you're going to actually make that move
though. You always talking about moving
somewhere. I want a sense of community.
I want somewhere I want this
shit. The end like, you know,
I just wanted to just want to be regular.
Like I don't see a future for me here.
If there is,
I'll stay here though. I, they buried me,
you know, they put me in that sag home.
What do you mean there's
nothing here though? I just,
I'm confused by that because I feel like,
I don't know,
I have a future comedy wise and I love
all that stuff, but let's face it,
you know,
the,
the other side of the industry has great
article came out about two weeks ago
when, and I'm not saying nothing
bad. I think the world would,
I think it was a great, I like crashing,
but we're crashing, got canceled.
A magazine put up that
when is it going to end?
That it's too late for America to accept
different types of comics that the
clean cut comic America has
all want to see it no more.
We've been pounded where they mentioned
the guy from crashing. They mentioned, uh,
John Malaney and they mentioned Sebastian
and this artist guys. All do great,
right?
Hugely successful
TV show would work like that because
it didn't work because of that.
It didn't work because
America's ready for a new,
and they even said it in the article.
If I was a television studio,
I be chasing the dirty
bulge on the Internet.
That to America really wants to see
those people with a little bit more,
you know, on regular friends,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I would like to re pitch a
show or something like that.
Maybe give myself a few chair,
but if it's just the work
the road and do a podcast,
you could do that from anywhere.
That's true.
A couple of weeks ago I went to
toast, so I'm sitting in the back. Uh,
Lee Wellington, the guy that runs their,
a great guy and his little assistant.
I go, I'm starving. Is Do you have
any menus study? When the guy goes,
look and taste them, it's a place
down the corner. Uh, fucking Tacos.
Bourdain went there and fine,
I'll bring your menu.
And he came back with a major, I didn't
even look at. I go, just get me, carnitas.
Get yourself some Tacos, get some
fully and get some for Kate Quigley.
I gave him $60 and I'm not a cheap guy.
He came back with a box of Tacos to
them and a bean and cheese burrito.
He gave me back $41 it was
$19 for fucking 16 Tacos,
bean and cheese burrito. You know, a
couple of weeks early, I went somewhere,
Saint Louis or something and I got
like a fucking huge lunch. Salmon,
mashed potatoes, salad, a
cup of fucking lentil soup.
I tea.
Yeah,
$12 I told the waitress she made
a mistake and she goes, no, that,
that's what the food costs.
And you come here and when you,
you see what differences.
Again, I'm not cheap.
I'm just talking about I want to go
somewhere where I don't feel I'm getting
fucked in the ass. You know, how
much longer are we going to pay?
$25 for fucking luggage. No, I
don't, but I'm just saying, you know,
you know how much law either yesterday,
tremendous.
The biggest deal in the fucking
angel history and games,
that guy, $437 million.
And all these angel fans.
What do you think's going to pay for that?
Now your tickets went from 69 to 89
what if you and Christina and your w two
little children want to go to a
fucking baseball game? It's crazy.
It's four times a yard stick plus 50 for
parking for seven for a to Disneyland.
That fucking costs a fortune. I'll tell
you what, Disney land justifies it.
You're going to tell you something.
When I go to Disney land,
if I turned around and Mickey Mouse
fucks me in the ass and I paid a one 19 I
get my money's worth
and I'll tell you why.
You know you're not going to get blown up.
You know you're not going to fall off
one of those fucking rights. The places,
Felipe Gum wrapper,
not doing a fucking
something does happen before.
There's a little fucking Mexican dude
with the sweeper with Mickey mouse ears on
that comes up right behind him.
Pick it the fuck up then don't fuck
around at Disneyland every day.
I went to Disneyland, pissed off
this last year. First of all,
I went to the Permian. Listen to me
tell you the hookup I got, I got,
I went to the premiere coke.
They couldn't find people named Coco,
so the guy goes,
how about Coco does I go,
that's my daughter would definitely
go see coke. So they took us downtown.
Seriously, just because of your
nicknames, because they took us downtown.
They're like, this guy's totally friendly.
Ooh, three floors, a fucking white people
martinis mixed with fucking shoe Polish
and CBD or with with my daughter and my
wife and their kid comes up
and he goes, Brian, I love you.
Or Rogan like you motherfuckers
are the real deal. If you ever
want to go to Disneyland.
He was my card. I got it.
I got a few of you want to call. My wife
wanted to go. I called the guy going, hey,
this is your DNS from cocoa, Hawaii.
I don't want to intrude. You know,
you feeling bad. You did say if there
was a hookup for Disneyland, he goes,
let me call you back.
He got me to Joe Rogan package.
The Joe Rogan packages drove it
or was, it just shows up, give it,
everybody gets it,
but they take them from caves.
He cuts through line. You know, the
guy gave me that deal for people.
I took my nieces and he brought his
kid and me and my wife and the tribe,
we stayed at the hotel. Awesome.
Two, three days. They walked around.
I walked around a little bit with
them. You know, there's some rides.
I can't do what?
That ride that you sit and you see the
world and you smell the dirt and they
throw dirt and all that shit all
around the world or something to say,
oh my fuck. Are you cutting
lines and shit? Right, right.
Through people he's doing.
Go for me. You're walking
around like fucking, you know,
you're walking around me foot deck.
He just walked back.
We won't cut through and people
want to be like, hey, we're,
what are you doing right
now? I think looking at, you
know, they know, they know.
People know. People know that you
know you're paying a little extra.
It's a lot of money. Yeah.
It's not no fucking jokes.
Oh yeah. Can you say? Yeah.
How much? 400 an hour.
400 an hour. And there's a
minimum for sure. Eight hours
for scratch. But you know me
and my little Jewish skills.
Yeah. Cut Down in half. You know
what I'm saying? You know what?
It was the Netflix thing. Yeah, I
took that Netflix, the first jacket.
I gave it to my wife and I go,
what do you want to do?
Disney land the best.
So let's go to Disneyland with
no concerns. You pay, you go,
you're getting fucked in the ass. But I
gotta be honest with what they have left.
That's a good fucking,
I gotta be honest.
I did not feel like I was getting fucked
and he didn't because every day you see
about these companies that are
roller coaster falls. Okay?
Yesterday on Carnival cruise, some fucking
white dude. It wasn't the bungee broke.
I'm taking my leg couldn't move. I'm
fucking going. Not a cruise ship.
Well goals a the fucking
fucking cruise ship on a cruise
ship shoot itself. Right.
The fuck now you cannot be that fucking
retarded walking around with three
fucking thousand people.
Yeah.
I hate even the same and a little fucking
room eating that fucking Maloof food
food dog. I'd rather, I wasn't
[inaudible] I gotta be terrible,
but that was because I was 21
she let me fucking with the ass.
We took the cruise around New York.
When you go outside New York,
you could gamble the whole thing, but
yeah, bring it back the next morning.
Okay,
so one night only horse shit.
It's like six nights and then,
and they make you sanitize your hands
before you go on the buffet because every
nasty motherfucker, it's coughing,
sneezing, touching, and then,
then they had an outbreak of
some orienting people every week.
This last thing,
every fucking week.
And what are you going to do on
a fucking boat for a week? Drink.
What's your book? Listen, go
to key west, right. The fucking
guy that take gap. Yeah.
I would much rather see can at a location.
Right?
How's your back or somewhere cool.
I will do that in groups.
Every time those groups die,
they die. They fucking die.
They don't like the group thing is flying.
The carnival cruise is a worst.
Is that what you did before
he was on a carnival?
I could just see the genius.
It's a hotel now. They take you out and
you're stuck with these fucking pee. Yeah.
You got to walk around. I don't want to
play shuffleboard. I don't want to bond.
Gee, I don't want to eat that fucking
buffet food. Oh, it's the worst.
It's the worst. I don't want to be on
a cruise. I want to go somewhere. I go,
first of all, I'm not a vacation type of
guy. No, you got to be for three days.
You got my attention for three days.
After three days, I start scratching.
Fucking acting it radically.
You know I've got to get the fire.
That's why Thursday, Friday,
Saturday, Sunday is the Lord's Day.
I love Sunday of weeks ago,
I broke it.
I went down to the stone on Monday.
That Sunday night for an all
things comedy showcase. Huh?
And I ate a bag of Dicks is I was
driving home. I was laughing. I go,
I'm not Lloyd's.
They type of cup in 1998 that Sundays
we're going to be a problem and by 2000 I
would just let people know. My favorite
thing about it though, you, by the way,
you haven't definitely set the precedent,
but my favorite thing about it is you
had the policy before you were really
selling out. Yeah, no,
that's the fucking baller thing is that
you guys don't understand when once you
sell tickets you can dictate things, you
know, and people were like, all right,
it's whatever you want to do both for.
You were selling tickets. You were like,
I just tell them to go fuck themselves.
And I was like, I would leave Rogan there.
Yeah, you would. Right.
He told me you left,
but before I left them two or three times,
you wouldn't talk to me for a month.
I told you already I don't work Sunday.
He's like, you would just be gone.
Pop It on, works on this.
Why you pop it on works.
The last thing you want to do on a
Monday, Bro. Just stick apart. Yeah,
that's horrible.
I'm telling you right now,
what do you really want to fuck around?
Take a flight on a Monday.
You're gonna stay till Tuesday to go to
a Yankee game or why is that? I get it.
Yeah. You know, but there's no reason
it works on this. Think about it.
What the fuck do you want to do?
First of all, I don't Miss 60 minutes.
Yeah, that's my mother fucking
shit. I have it recorded.
I don't miss it for nobody.
I don't Miss 60 minutes for no,
I don't want you to do it on a Sunday.
I imagine you're sitting in your boxers.
You smoke a little weed.
If I get home from the road,
first of all,
I'd take the first flight out of wherever.
Always it's called 6:00 AM 5:00
AM I get home. They go to church.
Okay,
so if I walk in the door at
nine 45 I am Lord my suitcase.
Set the sleep apnea machine up.
Take a shower cause that slight filthy.
The first thing I do though,
because my ass home knows the compass
and your ass on knows when you're away
from home. So when I'm on the road I'd
take minimal shits like eight inches,
six inches, little torpedo, minimal.
When I jumped in the Uber at the fuck,
at that point,
that's when my asshole starts calling
me late three days of what you believe.
And after you sent me photos, before I get
into the plane, I drink a Cam boot. You
move. Is that Kombucha? Kombucha,
whatever the fuck he gets.
Shit moving in your stomach of the plane.
It dropped a little,
went out on the plane.
You drop a little. Uh,
what do you mean you're shitting on
the plane? Are you still free? Shit.
Far to the started looking around.
So I dropped a few. Those get my
luggage by the time I get to you.
But I told the guy at midway and
I got to pick a tremendous shit.
So cause all of this fucking left lane
and get that fucking the high hop,
that Hov lane right now, cause I'm
there. I ain't got time to fuck around.
[inaudible] Laurel Canyon,
those pre far to come up.
I take the 20th I give it to the Uber
driver. I fucking run in the house.
I go to the back bathroom that has
a door that goes into my back yard.
I have three bathrooms
in that door. That bathroom is
priceless because I opened the door,
I sit home and there's a bong and a pipe
at a table next to me we'd underneath.
So I fill up the pipe and I hit it and
as I cough the shit slides out like
nothing like notes.
Bresson I'm not going to die like GG
and the sopranos backed up by Turkey
pushing.
You just call up her close and you just
feel those blocks coming out and then
you catch one of those midway ones
that's long. He's got to keep coughing.
She just feel it coming out of your ass.
Sometimes I go to Wa and I don't put my
ball sack and the thing you dark shit.
Hi. You put your balls out of
the toilet. Yeah, I don't never,
I don't want you gotta respect your wife.
What do you mean?
What do you mean you
don't put your bottom?
Put my balls because behind the toilet.
That's disgusting.
Next thing you know you're sucking
my balls and get a piece falls.
I don't put my, I don't put
my nuts. I pick them up,
put toilet paper and put it on my nuts.
Acts like arrest so my shit goes up higher
so it's got more room to go down like
a missile.
Then when I get up,
I piss on it and the pitcher
throws it down the hill.
The lodge just goes in and then I wipe.
I throw it on top of that and they flush.
I washed my hands and I'm ready.
Now I am to the suitcase.
I said machine.
I staple all the receipts
to plant that bad.
I can't imagine that your cleanup is easy.
Do you have a washlet a bit day?
I have a bad day to day goes
right the fuck.
I was not the best one.
You've been on the road and you smashing,
wiping with dry paper.
I love,
I love it. I fucking pressed
that. Then I got the hot water.
You sit there, you go into one
of those little fag trenches.
When they start those poppers,
you will see that Dude Katie
from Katie La, the one that Chris
Burroughs, they tried to hide this debt.
Real sweetheart of a guy, but they
found him in a hotel. When he died,
they put two meth rocks up his ass and
he had a mass crowd with no fucking
eyeballs and they had to poppers and is
known as the guys were Fist Fang him. No,
the guy was assisting him in
the fucking ass. Jesus Christ.
Alicia use cocaine and nothing to really
put your finger up my ass with speed.
I at least put some Novacane so he was
a dentist gives you something, right?
He was a real savage.
Yeah.
This guy was inside at the pink look like,
what's the word where you meet gay people?
There's no more real, yeah. Real. Oh
yeah. I guess there's no real facts.
No, there's no real, not the left.
This morning I woke up to taking care of
business. Remember? Got Stolen by beat?
Yes.
Yeah. That's what I'm white
people with white people. Yeah.
When they took care of business.
They didn't care about nothing that
came out like the 75 it was just dirty.
White people take it,
Kara.
This like my daughter hears and
she's like taking care of biscuits.
Biscuits. This bitch. You
got to take care of business.
That's all white people were wiping.
Yeah. That's where you took care of.
You took care of fucking business.
It's not like that anymore,
but was looking around
and we'll save the whales,
but last May I got to talk to fucking
what the fuck? A little fag from
the New York Times right now.
People will you give a fuck. Okay.
Y'All fucking family. Your father.
Fuck this daughter. Meanwhile you're
ratting on people. What's your take on Mj?
Michael Jackson. I think he did that
stuff. Never. Neverland. Yeah. Yeah.
The first out of my boat when I came
from Cuba was Michael Jackson. ABC. Yeah.
I love Michael Jackson with all my heart.
I love what the Jackson five did.
I still remember that last hour moving
violation when Jermaine left and the
whole,
I mean I lived through all that shit.
I watched both episodes with
an open mind and most people,
most Americans won't. People Watch that
like, wow, I was the parents fault.
Well again,
we got,
have you ever worked
on a kid show animated?
Have you worked on the kid
show? I get Disney show. No,
I didn't know what Hollywood was
about. Two, I worked at Disney show.
It's not about the kids,
it's about the moms.
Okay, so the mom show
up, they got the kids,
the kids are acting.
You look at the moms at rehearsal Tuesday,
Wednesday at the table,
read the whole thing, blocking on
Thursday on shoot day. Christine's,
you got to look at these fucking
cleavages out.
Miniskirt the registered around
tits are out there here and made up,
blow out.
Everybody wants to be Kim Kardashian.
And you're looking at them and they're
living their life to that children.
You know, I would talk to the
moms and they would go, oh,
we live in Weehawken because our kid
was doing a play in New York. And I go,
where do you usually live in? Look,
come from Kentucky. And I'm like,
where's your heart?
He's in homework.
We're out here living in Burbank in a
studio apartment, trying to get roles,
you know, and it was really like, it
really showed me like, what makes a woman?
I could see a kid, but now you're
pushing it. They were like,
pistol Pete's father,
pistol Pete Maravich.
It would beat them if they lost like
that, that we're talking about. Never,
never land. When I got,
when I did the longest yard,
I got caught up when it's very tough,
not too caught up.
Went with like the Hollywood thing.
Very tough with you say cut
and everybody's laughing
and you do the same thing
six times and people laugh and people
blow smoke up your ass and this movie
comes out, you know, blow up. You know,
you buy it at one time when this career,
you bought it at one time you
bought it and then it's gone away.
You see it for what it is that
they're all a bunch of motherfuckers.
You know when you watch the
Elvis documentary, he says,
it is old father. I said, we
realize he was damaged goods.
Our role, our role, our job was just
to put 'em out bed so we died. Yeah,
the captain,
what were the criminals and it's about
his own fucking where pieces of meat.
We're replaceable. It's six years on
new terms ago. It shows up in Montreal.
Yeah. Nobody's returning
your calls. That's,
but we get caught up when
you watch the documentary a,
I do believe both those boys be,
I feel bad for the parents
because it was just taken dick,
if we're in the business and we got taken,
think about it.
What would you feel? What would
you feel like right now? Fucking,
I don't even know was a
mega star like that anymore.
Took interest in your child and say
your child had talent and we're going to
take him to the top and I got a
rehearsal studio right down the corner.
Drop him off every day at three.
You're going to come for a few days then.
I know, but knowing what we know
about this business, like I,
I would never put my children
in the show business.
Like who wants to have her kid working
when they're four or five years old?
It's not cool. I don't want that. Life
is terrible. Take come to my child.
I don't want it. They can't see it. But
when you're from some, but they weren't.
These people were from California.
No one was from Australia
valley and the other ones were
from California. Yeah, right.
But still Michael Jackson come
at the house and see me crazy.
You got to remember he bought her a
house. He loaned them money for AF. Yeah.
And then he told her was a gift
that they want the money back.
There's so many different variables.
I'm not mad at the parents.
It happens to us as at the
table when we come here,
they give us a show. We
actually buy, you know,
how many people have we seen
come and go this time? Oh my God.
What do you think they left
here with a sober mind.
Everything is for me. No. Yeah.
They left here with a smack
to their fucking face. Yeah.
How many chicks really
did come in and blow?
Nasty guys didn't get anything
I could think of that have them,
that suck my dick and then
how to handle them. Well,
I'll get you a spot at the fucking comedy
store and next [inaudible] helmet got
behind the car.
Another one reminds me of this topic.
We just had,
remember that that executive at what
studio? And he was promising. Oh yeah.
Warner brothers. Yeah. And
he was promising these girls
like, Hey, if you fuck me,
I'm going to give you roles and
this and that. And he never followed
through. And we were like, that's so
cruel. Like you're a multimillionaire.
You don't need to spit that game.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you could have just gotten
your dick sucked just by being rich.
What if you have that
vulnerable? Yeah, I went to a
great place,
but after a couple seeds and then they
find that you were staying though.
I had these girls showed up at the store.
I'm like, Oh my God, you're so great.
You have an agent.
They'd never seen that as a college
girls that watched met live. Yeah.
I think Betty could clamp was shit.
They love Reese Witherspoon, whatever.
I could do a restart something.
The most popular girl,
they come out here and you're up
against all the popular girls and Reese
Witherspoon's been enacting
since she was a baby. Yet
you've got that and they come out here
when they get caught up and agents,
and I can't tell you how many I could
name like four times a woman look me in
the eye and said to me,
I'll do anything to get an agent
if you get me with your agent.
And this is when I was like,
what fucking low level studio.
You call them boutique agents.
Really? And I would go,
anything, anything. Oh my God,
I really want to be an actress. Ever
since I saw the Hollywood sign, you know,
they be able to have the right reasons.
They don't even know why they're doing it.
They just think that they're
going to go from zero to four.
How many fucking dicks?
Marilyn Monroe side.
Oh God, I wish I would've done that. Jay.
Ryan a fucking train on mountain.
They fucked the eight.
They fucked her to bet that
didn't shadow with something.
So she would shut the fuck up.
She shot.
She fucked so many people they killed
just to listen to you can't, you can't.
Harvey must've seen it to me is,
well he was like three
everybody fuck this shit out.
They were passing her around
all the way to the press. Man,
this is depressed as fuck.
No Shit.
No sure.
Those are the ones they want.
They don't want the ones
that are five Beta Kappas.
You're not going to put it
over on there. Yeah. That
grows at a goal you can go to.
You ever go to even do a TV show or
movie that you go to the party and you're
just really want to fucking be there
and you see people from the movie,
you wave at them. But then there's
this other 60 women that are,
that that black, they're white,
they're Chinese, they got Afros,
they got tight suits on,
and at one point in the night,
the hors d'oeuvre comes by
and just look at them and go,
I don't remember me from the movie. I'm
Joey, and though I wasn't in the movie,
I'm just here because my from he
gives me other sub deck. Yeah.
When people telling me I'm there to
support Tom, you're here to suck Dick.
You're here to suck a dick in one form or
another. You know, you have a showcase.
The old days, if you have a
showcase at the comedy store, sure.
They put an asterisk next to your name
and comics would just go down and see
what an asterick and they would wait
till you were talking to somebody,
come over and crack a joke.
Let me do you. And you're like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Because they knew you had a showcase
then they were trying to talk to whoever.
You know, we will. We would, we had,
we are instinctively whores when we
first move here. It's not our fault.
We're just horse,
not literally whores sucking Dick,
but we would do and put up with
things we would usually put up with.
Are you going up 12th you know,
but it's nine o'clock he's going to
be up about midnight, shit like that.
And we buy into it.
There's one day that you wake up and go,
this is not going to happen no more.
Right,
and for me it was an Arby's commercial.
I did a Hardee's,
what's the other side of the Hardee's?
Carl's Jr. I did three commercials
and the three weeks in a row,
three nationals and I was clean and
sober from coke and when I got clean I
remember saying to myself, you know
what? Before I was a fucking comic,
I was a man, but slapping people
enough with that dumb Hollywood game,
if you got a common theme that
I'm going to give it to you.
And I remember having that frame thought,
getting the Hardee's commercial
and going down to Long Beach.
The call was midnight and I play a mobster
with this other guy and they put us
in an SUV. We got to pull up to
shoot a guy, but when we got there,
the guy was eat the chicken Parmesan
sandwich and there was saw something
mistake. So he was passed out. We
thought somebody got there first.
So we get there.
But my profile before I got the
commercial like you're working with,
you know Antonio and Gillini, this
tremendous director, you know,
he gets there with the assistant next
to him. He's got the pepe Le Pew Hat,
the shirt role.
Does he see this tattoo?
You know my new philosophy is if
I could tell you the director,
I don't want to be in the movie.
Yeah.
If you've got that direct,
the garb on and all that shit.
I'm done with you. Yeah, I heard
that man. If you got the costume on,
I don't want to work with your fucking
Douche bag. I don't want to work.
So what happens on this?
This,
Oh my God, I'm off the powder.
I'm just, I'm referring,
I'm a fucking savage.
I get made pressers up
and this is mafia outfits.
They put lights inside the
car so they would disconnect.
They put the lights on there
must have disconnected the break.
So our job was to drive like 30 yards,
stop,
slammed the door and walk towards the car.
Every time I slammed the door,
the car kept rowing and they would
take cut and the guy would go,
what the hell is going on? Put the brakes
on. And I'm like, I put the brakes,
the brakes on it. On, sorry,
let's do it again and again.
And I put the emergency, I'm like,
get out the fucking cars rolling.
This happened like two or three
times and the director kept saying,
I don't know what the fuck
is going on with youtube,
but somebody better figure it out.
And finally the guys went in there
and tried to fix it and again,
I put it on and the guy goes,
you're not pulling it hard enough.
You fucking dummy.
I turned around,
it was about two in the morning and
I go, what'd you say? Motherfucker
just froze time. And I walked towards
my, or would you say mother fuck.
I'm like, listen, I'm not one of
your punk white fucking frenzy.
I'll knock you the fuck out right now.
You ran from me.
The assistant and the PA took them and
ran them into his trailer and he closed
himself in there and I walked to the
trail. I've banged on the door. I go,
you're not getting away
with this one bitch. I go,
come on here and talk to me like a man.
He goes,
I'm on the phone with the whatever.
We're replacing you. I go,
it's two in the morning.
You dumb motherfucker.
You're never going to replace
me at two in the morning.
Come out here and like a man.
Then the came out, he said,
walk away from the door.
I go and then the first
day they came out and go,
come calling the police to go
call the police. Well, the police,
what are you going to do?
Nothing happening. It's
just two men trying to talk.
I go, come out of the
fucking trailer and be a man.
Then there's little faggy assistant
came out with the feather in her hat and
then he finally opened the door and he
goes, nobody has ever spoken to about it.
I go, that's what your problem
is. We all put our pants,
we all put our pants on one leg at a time.
You respect me and I fucked him.
Respect to you.
That's what men do.
But they blown you off to smoke up your
ass assistant and all his people there.
And I'm going, you got to
act like a fucking man. Okay.
You don't talk to people that way.
You talk to people like a fucking man.
Why come from you get hit and that's it.
Let's finish this fucking commercial.
Let's go. And I turned around
like I follow me very meekly.
We'd get like eight takes and he
caught me, you can go home now.
And I walked away and I walked up and
put my hand down and he was still a con
teeth. He, you know, faculty
put his hand down and I go,
you got to act like a man.
So okay, you got to be a man.
Forget this director Shit.
And as I got to the car,
his assistant came up to me and she goes,
thank you very much.
Sometimes people forget what our
main job is to be human beings.
Thank you. And she goes, I'm happy you
did that. I'm very happy you did that.
You scared him to death. I fucked him.
Told him I was bagging him on the trail.
It will come on here like
a man. No fighting. This is
about two men talking. Yeah,
come out here but you don't call
me a fucking dummy bitch. No,
don't even ever say that to somebody on
the set. You don't pay us enough. Yeah.
And he worked with me like, like
I said, it took one more here.
He was saying we're going to work all
night. Yeah. So just do the fucking cuts.
Just do the trick and us,
I'm not going to sit here all night
and do fucking takes. Ah. You know,
like when I did go daddy,
they made me call the pizza
up a thousand times. I said,
that's it no more.
If you didn't get it by now,
go back to USD fucking acting
school and got a camera again.
And they all looked at me and
I fucking went and sat down.
That's it enough with this bullshit.
You want to kill four hours,
be throwing the pizza.
Yeah,
go fuck yourself.
You're never going to use this film shit.
And then you see the thing of this,
you move on into like,
I was there for six fucking hours.
No, for what? This
business is so wasteful.
This is the only business where everything
is done last minute and they waste a
tremendous amount of money.
It's just gone down the fucking toilet.
Oh we, we got to, we need a lama for this
thing tomorrow. Let's spend 50 grand.
Those find the wrangler.
Let's change the set.
You know when you are working
on various projects, right?
They don't have a call time for you
until last fucking minute. So disrespect,
fly him in and then it's like,
God,
the waste money, we're going to,
you're working all day tomorrow. Okay.
And then you get through like Jackie,
you're not going to work then like what?
Yeah, I find that we'd decided we'd
move some things around and we're gonna,
we found this up. We're going,
we're want to do this shot we got,
but we got to bring in this special
light and it's like 45 grand to use it.
And you're like,
yeah,
it is very like just impulsive last minute
and we're going to do this thing like,
oh, okay. You don't, you
don't waste a lot of,
it's a fucking thinking
about that in advance.
Nothing bothers me more than that shit.
Yeah. Ah, how do you feel, by the way,
this is totally off topic, but we've
been having this debate about, she,
she taught our son who's
three years old to say,
I have to take a dump. And I'm like, come
on now. He's going to say it. Teachers.
Yeah, the smile on his face. I
think it's funny. It's funny.
It's funny to think about
like people being like, what,
you know, like adults treating him
differently because he speaking Kras,
here's the deal. Yeah. You don't
why I got a potty mouth. Why?
Because after three they
thought it was cute.
They really thought it was cute.
But what it is is it's unrecoverable,
what's that word I wrote?
Everybody. Vocable vocable yeah.
So once it goes down that
path, oh, I am teaching math.
I tell mercy like when she takes a
shower, when she comes out, like,
what did you wash your monkey? She'll look
at me. I go, did you wash your muffling?
She'll say, yes, Daddy.
And she knows, right?
I don't think she goes to school and
says, Hey, I washed my monkey yet.
Even besides that, I'm no
fucking angel either. Yeah.
But I don't curse around that.
No. Well, listen, that's where I draw
the line. I, we don't drop f bombs.
I don't say shit or go fuck yourself.
None like that.
But I feel like dump is permissible.
It's not really a bad word. It's,
it's crass. As my daughter would call
it. She say potty words that Heidi,
she's sick.
Bollywood's I'm like, what type
of words? You know, she won't say,
she's heard me. I slept with a
shift from dying. It's impossible,
but nothing else like that.
Nothing.
Now I bet with your history of
being an animal and the coke days,
you've been with some real
fucking animals yourself,
chicks at are real fucking questionable.
Right. There's definitely been some,
but I want to show you this clip of this
chick and tell me if she could get it
back. And Joey Diaz is
crazy days. Go ahead.
[inaudible]
I mean you could tell by her
eyes that other just chicks off.
She would leave you alone like you die.
She's a stalker. Look good. Look at it.
Everybody molested her.
Her father, the neighbor.
Look at it. Look in her eyes.
She's got crazy eyes. Everybody.
Everybody. Everybody. She bumped
into did something to this.
Grow a finger in her ass.
They through holy water around.
Look at it.
She's fucking retarded.
How the fuck are you going to lick
a fucking toilet? See what the fuck
man. That she'd be fun cause
you could just tell, listen,
stick your tongue up my ass and target.
I'm going to jerk off like your hair and
your all and she'd be like, all right.
All right. Yeah, that's
a good, that's what
the animal looks at Tom. You're going
to have an itchy assholes for two years.
You'd have to go to the doctor and they
got to put you in stirpes like they do
the women in open public camera put corn
starch powder in your ass because you
got rashes and shit.
That's a nasty bitch.
Take that off. I'd rather see a
woman he shit or something like that.
Don't make a fuck. Yes.
One of the nastiest things,
I've never been with animals like I throw
them out or give them a lethal lethal
doses optimally shut them the
fuck up for an hour. I mean,
isn't that one of the
grossest things you seen?
We've seen a lot of shit on the show
be like top worst. Yeah. And
by the way, I respect her.
I think she's just cool.
What is the other respect?
Respecting Brown.
That's who fucking the
owner of new English.
Who the fuck do you see a girl like that?
You give a 10,000 she's gotta be retarded.
Something something to somebody.
Her family's artistic substances.
You give her 30 grand and you tell it
snapped. I fucking, I'm gonna kill you.
Just cut a check to your family.
We'll drop you off on the one
70 you'll never find anybody.
That's what you do with chicks like that.
Somebody know families died from,
so yeah. All right. Listen,
you give her the cash though.
Look what he's going through too.
Fucking some middle grade. Yeah.
That's got no paperwork for
getting the rusty hand job,
but chick with dry hands and
fucking Jupiter, Florida,
some fucking Shin Shin would dry hedge.
Jupiter, Florida were going to hand job.
I have somebody to dry heads that
nice. You know what I'm saying? Yeah.
They better
fucking those little fucking
human trafficking heads.
They've been scratching and ships
and fucking scratching his ship.
I don't want to go. No. I said
do the potlucks now, but boy,
they landed to throw up the Atlanta
with the helicopter and the guy's like,
I don't want to go. I
don't want to go there. Oh,
they just come with the house over there
in China Ville or they pull you out.
You got your fingers in the dirt. They're
pulling you by your legs like the Fag.
It's fucking dark.
Goes the second season when they
buried him with a them with half of the
motorcycle. The two factors will make
an house swapping the spirit. Oh,
how did he hit him in the head with
a bottle? They fucking toys. Huh?
You guys are fucking crazy. Listen one
who gives a fuck? I don't give a fuck.
[inaudible] think one question though.
What is she trying to show?
How nasty she is?
She's just nasty.
Really Nasty. Are just nasty.
She, that's her own quote there.
It says if you're listening,
it says she captioned Blake
in the airplane toilet
because I'm gross like that.
So yeah, she put it out there.
That was the flying too by the way.
I would have her suck my ass hole.
Why?
I stuck my phone guide toe and her
pussy is, it doesn't really matter.
You know this guy and after that
a policy would look like, like,
like it just like a fuck my whole Fred
Flinstone foot if the cat has got it.
George,
why do they shadow with a cannon
or your feet nasty like a motherfucker?
I do. You know, I get the,
I put cream on my feet and shit,
but I got a phone.
That toenail toenails are top down.
I Love Buffalo. It like once. Yeah,
I do it on the road. I do to their hotel
room. I got the whole, yes, I got the z.
What the fuck did the Braider and
you see the dust just go flow.
I save it and I put it together into
a circle, like a little volcano.
When I smell it.
Ah,
was I put it in a baggy and say with a
sprinkle in some of these fucking house.
Got a little fun guy fucking told us.
Oh Nasty. Joey Diaz. I cut the nails.
Then you've got to go under the
nail and take the fun guy out. Yeah,
because the the fun guy,
so I got to cut it and then
scrape it. Oh clubs. I do.
I was asking that.
I do it like on a black piece
of paper and then I scrape.
Well it all up the travel with a black
piece of paper. Oh yeah. Well yeah.
Listen to me. I got like an eight ball of
toad. Does that. We're Dale. What do you
do with the care? Why? Just look at it
for a little while and then I rub it.
I smell it. I fucking blow away and I
want to fuck you. I'm going to throw up.
I got the machine that you buffed it nail
and then the powder falls all over my
other toes. Anyway. I've seen you do this
shit now. You keep it from her. Yeah.
That's nice of, I want you to, I want to,
I'm so cute. I've never met your wife.
My wife is died opposite.
Married to Joey.
He's the opposite of me. Completely
alien creatures. Podcasts.
You want to know about her?
She was on Leanne's wife of the party.
What it's like to be married to Joey Diaz.
She's cool as shit.
I like my wife
and she's cool as shit.
I live, so I'm grateful.
I live with a really peaceful fucking now.
Yeah. Yeah. Which is very rare where
I came from houses today, buddy. Yeah.
Yelling and screaming and arguments.
People walk with two in the morning.
Wow.
Same Way.
I don't want any fucking drama and chaos
of how I wanted to live and
I'm living in that that way.
Peaceful. Yeah. I know my schedule. I'd
go out Tuesdays, Thursdays and Saturday.
Friday night's date night.
Oh, I can't get her out.
She's got to talk to some adults. Yeah.
I think if a Cuban food is silver lake,
you stop at a Starbucks. We're home by
nine 30 10 who always do early days.
We tried to go somewhere like
some restaurant, some different,
we went to the Italian joint,
got the meatball two weeks ago,
so every Friday we do
something to Saturdays.
You've got to do some comedy
somewhere. Yeah. You know you do it.
Nine 15 at the store maybe jumped off the
belly room and then you split the same
way. I am home 20 years. What do you
want to talk about? We have call me,
just call me.
I'm going to sit down there.
It's very nice to go down there and see
people like on Tuesday nights when I'm
driving down there,
I'm very excited to go down there
and watch Christine act either.
I like to go down there,
get high before I leave the house
and by the time I get down there,
I'm really tuned up.
I get a water and they sit in those back
chairs and I try to watch the four acts
before me with nobody bothering me.
Just to see what you're up to.
Bert Kreischer last week was
married Ali Wong and then me.
I get to see. So you'll watch
different. Absolutely. Yeah, because
I don't want to watch on TV.
I read a little watcher.
Can I tell you something?
I've known you for so long and you look
amazing right now. Thank you. I Dunno.
What are you doing? Cause you look,
doesn't he look healthy? You Look
Jujitsu. He's doing his
boxing. The biggest thing,
right? Learn from in the last
10 years was the episode he
had about the guy, about sleep.
I that I was thinking about
that episode yesterday. I was,
that episode changed my life
and that book changed my life.
What is it so people can get it,
uh,
what's the book? Sleeping while
we sleep? Something weird.
I learned a lot from when
I had the sleep apnea,
but now I've taken up to a level.
I got the same problem top man,
you got home at 11 o'clock for the
comedy store. Eat an apple, eat a banana.
You try to unwind.
You're not just going to go in and kick
your shoes off and way down two spots at
the store. You go down, you're going
to have a computer and look at Twitter,
thanked them for coming to the store.
You look at your, I did good today.
I got to change this joke around
and then you have that low
and I'm the type of guy,
if I go in the living room and
man on fires, yeah, that's it.
I get up, get the fucking
cold cuts out. Yeah,
I got a coke zero and I
watch the fucking movie.
I go during commercial for our stop and
I go hit the bong and the things and now
it's 10 to two and now we're at two
o'clock. Guess what's coming on.
Smoke gave the man.
Now I gotta sit here and watch this
fucking thing because how am I going to go
to sleep now?
How old are fucking my had to go lay down
while I'm fucking police in class died
and left me boss. Yeah, yeah. No,
that was going on that I wasn't
on the road and splash resigned,
junk canvas best John Candy was just
brilliant and on the road you'll watch it
until like four C I love,
I love flying in Thursday.
Yeah.
Doing that show Friday and then that
Friday you just tell people like,
people were like,
what are you doing tomorrow?
Do you want to do lunch at
a little? Listen, go away.
I'll call you when I wake up because I'm
going to go back and I'm going to have
a film festival. Yeah, no,
I got a little bit of food.
I get those protein bars and I put them
in my sax with those protein milkshakes.
I put them in my sock and that's the
only night that I go off the reservation.
You know, sometimes you get so fucking
high, like I don't do the vapor pens.
At home. I only bring them on the roads.
So when I go on the road with them,
I get high in my room, you
know, sometimes whatever.
But when I'm home Jack,
there's no 10 30 fucking main shows
from my world though. That shit,
because that starts at 11 it next,
you know,
I'm walking to my house at 1215
that meets to add in my house.
You wake up at six 15 whether
you like it or not Friday.
So in our position we got to get eight me.
If I could do seven 1130 12 to seven
sometimes I'll sleep till seven get up,
jump in the shower, I have a cup of
coffee, talk with her for 1520 minutes,
and then maybe they go to
school and I write for an hour.
They're not going to kick at night.
I do that shit early.
You get it out of the way,
you know?
But the sleep has been
asleep is fucking huge.
If you're dieting and you're not
sleeping, you know, losing weight.
If you lift the weights and you're not
sleeping, you're not fucking retiring.
It backup. So if anything, I
blame it on sleep. Yeah, that,
that episode, by the way,
I don't know what it is,
but if you guys,
if you just Google your rug and
sleep expert, this guy in the,
in the first few minutes of that episode,
that guy has you thinking about, is
that episode 1109? That's what it is.
Yeah. It's jre 11 or nine, I forget.
I don't know what the guy's name.
He's a sleep expert and a
neuroscientist man. That, that dude,
in the first few minutes he starts
explaining what happens to your brain and
grabbing people without having great
sleep. Um, but that is asleep. Put dirty.
Totally separate. Really for 27,
I did blow out what our own, uh,
Chris, who's working here? That
was his professor in school.
What's it really? Yeah, that was
definitely my professor Walker.
Okay.
What's the name of the book?
You know the name of the boat is the name
of the book. I didn't catch that. Um,
sleep. Look Up Matt Walker. Yeah.
So I got to watch everything
because if I drink too much water,
then I'm up and down
as the base thing.
So now if I go to bed 1130
while we sleep,
I could sleep till six so I pee.
I don't have nothing going for my
blog. I go back, close my eyes,
and I try to get one more out.
The last two nights I've slept so well
and I feel different. Yeah, that's,
that's either you can eat well,
you could do everything.
But if you'll remember when
I first started the podcast,
I was doing it at 6:00 AM
I was telling Tom that,
Christine, you want to be on my show, I'm
going to call you at 6:00 AM. I was like,
ah,
I don't wake up exam 45 I was getting up.
So it was doing that.
I was getting up at four 45 Monday,
four 45 Wednesday for Thursday,
the fly out and then Friday radio dude.
And what time are you going
to bed? Usually? No, whatever.
No restraint was tools
that flicks documentaries,
this dat, you know, youtube concerts.
Now everything gets shut down.
But why were you waking up so
early if he didn't have to pick?
Because I read the Howard stern book
years ago and he said that when he did
radio,
he always wanted to get to you first.
That's the reason why he did morning
radio was to get to you first.
I was trying to build a podcast,
so I want to get to you first. Oh,
that's interesting. I never got a
reason why I was doing that for so long.
I wanted to get to you first. It
lasted about two years. We did it.
I couldn't believe it. I
couldn't it. I did it once. I
called in and you were like,
I'll call you at six. I was
like, I was like, fuck. It was,
I started thinking about it and it was
too much. Like morning radio. Yeah.
What I was trying to avoid,
I had become,
so now like I consider a
podcast or why at the APP.
My podcast should be a why at that.
I see always people wasting valuable
time on a fucking podcast. I'm like golf.
They play games, they do
this. They called his talk.
People just want to hear why at that.
That's all we are,
what we would say behind closed doors,
but they want to hear for sure.
They want to hear, they don't
want to hear if you edit me out.
Oh he said Chin Chin.
He says this.
That's not what they want to fuck it here.
They want to hit a wire tap where
they hear a fucking why for sure.
A conversation between two fucking guys,
woman to what we were talking about.
Yeah, it's true. It's
pretty fucking by the way.
You have any interest and you kind of
just watched from the sidelines how things
are starting to gear up for 20,
20 elections and all these
people are coming into the mix.
Like different people are announcing
that they're going to right now the pool,
I don't know if you've seen the democratic
pool. It is like, it's um, it's,
it's huge,
right?
Every day announcing like all these
different senators and former governors
congresspeople.
But there's,
there's other people that are announcing
that they're going to run for president
to like, um, I don't know if you've
seen this guy right here. He's,
he just announced,
hi everyone.
Did she scream my co Ah,
Taylor jr I am a retire e I am running
for president of United States.
Good
fucking Brody hung up.
So this guy still fucking
walking around telling people,
here's the problem with him.
Oh, Brody rest his soul.
And this guy wants to run for president.
This guy can't get to the fucking store
without falling down two times and he
wants to run for president.
And the fact that somebody taped him
and let it this fucking Moron get the
platform. Like if this guy calls
you up and said, come over,
I want you to tape me. And when
they run for president, yeah,
I'll be there in two hours.
I'd send the mental health people over
there like listened to go over there and
just bandage him up.
He's talking about killing themselves
and take him out of fucking Rovs.
And then somebody had to
upload this to youtube. Listen,
you know what the thing is, when I
came from Cuba, I looked at the prices.
You know, you had your Nixon's, you had
your, you had your fucking, uh, you know,
I can't even remember for Reagan,
Reagan,
Ford Hall look like presence.
And then Clinton came along and he got
his dick sucked and something happened
and that, that nobody
else got the Dixon. Yeah.
He came along and it became
something else. Bushed it to have it.
I think Bush had it, but
he did. Then the sun,
they definitely didn't fucking habit.
We don't have precedence anymore.
We got a bunch of jokesters. Yeah.
No, nobody in the pool was exciting.
Nobody's excited,
but nobody has a presence.
Joe Biden has a presence is
2000 years old. Once a you,
you hit him with a challenging, you
know, the Koreans are common. I can die.
Would be,
I never even had Korean food
over to Korea town bastard.
So these guys, you know, I need a 55
year old with a strong top barrel.
Yeah.
He'd come across a guy like John Paul,
like a throwback to like, uh, or like if
a madness actually ran, you know, the guy,
a general Maddis. I like that. Who's like,
we haven't had a general in a while. I
think that'd be, or you know, I want it.
There was only, I don't
vote. I'm a felon. Yeah.
But that wasn't one motherfucker
I would have ever voted for it.
His name was Ross Perot.
Oh yeah.
I read the, I read his book. It was in
prison and I was never more impressed
when you read his book on wings of Eagles
is when, if you really,
really, really are an American,
if you really believe that we should
fuck motherfuckers up when they slip.
You know what I'm saying?
Fuck.
Motherfuckers up like parole was our
guy primrose claim to fame was he owned
this company.
I don't know what his people
got kidnapped and they uh,
ran Iraq situation or something.
Correct me. I'm not a fucking historian.
And I read this book in [inaudible] 88
but he went to Kissinger and he went to
all the heads of state and they said they
really couldn't help him. And he said,
okay. And he went to the
people's families and he goes,
I'm going to have your
family back by Christmas Day.
And he went and he searched
for the highest ranking
retired fucking killer that
the military ever have. Like you pay like
10 million. Give me the fucking coach.
I want somebody who's killed a
thousand Jack. He's killed everybody.
Cubans.
I want a guy with no conscious.
And he took that guy that was played by
the movie cause they did a movie about
it.
He was played by a tough white
dude to train his employees.
So think of you're an it guy.
Like can I come in and go get up,
let's go shoot a fucking grenade
missile. He, she trained,
this guy says trends his own employees
because Ross Perot sold him on it.
Those are your brothers over there.
Can you sit on that fucking basket?
Eight fucking crackers.
Let's go.
He trained them and Christmas Eve,
the 23rd around there,
they went over there and they saved his
employees and he had the people back to
their families.
Shit.
Something the government wouldn't even
do cause they don't want to cause bro.
Yeah. Wow. Parole got in some trouble
for it. So he had some backlash. Yeah.
My world.
I want that backlash.
Went to a family and
told them no matter what,
even if I got to buy helicopters,
I will go over and take them myself.
It takes a certain type of man to do that.
He was,
he would have been a scary presence.
Yeah.
They would've been like two
countries left. He was the president.
He would have been like us. He would
have blown everybody else up. Africa,
I ran these real Railey's would still
be around and see where the team that
we've got team up with Jews.
Every Jewish people know a thing or two.
You know what I'm saying? I'm
Palestinians. Just take them out.
They would just been parking lots all
over this fucking empty fucking places.
Smoking.
I remember like those,
he wasn't going to fuck around
Larry King and he was here.
It sounded like someone's uncle,
you know, just shooting the shit.
And then at the end of every
thing, he was going, by the way,
American people dead paying
for this with your money.
I'm paying for this money.
I saw when he was making at one time guys,
it was just amazing.
Yeah. I one time they broke down when he
was making a day. It's got to be insane.
It was insane when he had that much
money and he's still alive. By the way,
did this guy have some platform that he
was running on? Who? Ross Perot? No. No.
The guy that announced his running for
press, the fucking mobile platform.
What did he once he actually say,
who's this? Who's this? I don't know.
Can you imagine the other four idiots
now who's going to be his vice president,
guy with a hat with a propeller on
it. Then they sit there all day. Yeah,
this is what I'm going to do.
Got The fuck out of here.
You got to drive me crazy with this shit
and freedom for freedom and I am
taking the wall down. Oh,
he's taking the wall. Okay,
so he's got an immigration policy.
That's interesting to know the wall.
No need to be up and Masha cow,
aeration dishes
America.
You're going to hell Tom,
who's willing to have this guy?
Can you imagine this poor bastard giving
this first beach and all the sudden you
just hear it happens that fly off
and shit and he's still alive.
I think we need a wall.
Let me tell you.
So they can put up 20 walls.
Those Mexicans, they're
worse than the Vietnamese.
Don't dig up though. They'll
dig it up, dog. You can't stop.
You can't stop it. You
can't. You can't stop people.
What they've been doing
for the last 200 years,
they know shit about that fucking
born that we don't have a phone.
You ever been to a checkpoint? Charlie
in Berlin ever go to Germany and Berlin.
Oh, you should have seen him
over there all the time. So I do.
I go a little talk about
Jews with the Nazis
got to go to for led by top.
Mother's the,
when you think of those Jews
that fuck is wrong with you.
End Up in Berlin.
You got see the checkpoint Charlie.
It's the place where you could cross
between east and West Berlin because they
built a wall. That's what they fucking
did after the end of the war. Whatever.
The crowds, the crowds. Yeah. Yeah.
And you would see it's a mute.
There's a museum right there and it shows
exactly how everybody fuck the wall.
Basically.
Like people would sneak in,
they build compartment secret
compartments and trunks.
They built secret compartments under cars
and carriages and people still fucking
snuck in. I mean there's museums dedicated
to it. So you can't stop anybody. No,
it's never going to find that you can't,
you can't jump over and get shot.
You won't fucking,
we'll just do it. Did you watch that last
season of Narcos? Yeah. That's been it.
Yeah. Yeah. Go Luna. Awesome.
Amazing. Just tremendous.
But it tells you that
they didn't give a fuck.
They'll build tunnels. Yeah,
man, don't go down the,
they'll figure out some marines
that don't give a fuck. Yeah.
It's such a, you got to pick your battles.
Do you know what I'm saying? Yeah.
I have nothing against the wall.
The wall that discriminant
but build the fuck on wall,
but you're not going to stop it.
You're not going to stop you though.
And that money? No, I don't
even like talking politics. No.
Humans are so resilient. They'll
just figure out a way. Get through.
My parents escaped from Hungary and
69 when the Russians were. Yeah.
For all those Mexicans are built on a
hot air balloon as we speak right now.
Horse.
Do you think the fucking new flight with
a butane lighter like three Mexicans by
themselves,
a little fucking thing that pops after
the fucking an hour that just build this
shit already countering the wall.
They're already planning how the fuck
they gonna zipped a little war. Oh yeah.
And by the way, the, you
know the way that people,
whenever somebody faces any Perrier
of something they want to do,
there's always another, there's
always another way, man. Horse.
It'd be another way you can,
you can put up a hundred foot wall
and then a new way. Just a new way in.
Of course my parents figured out a way
to escape from communist Hungary where
kids were ratting out their own parents
to the KGB and your fucking family would
get taken away in the middle of
the night and thrown into prison.
And my parents were like, fuck this place.
We're Audi. How'd they get out of it?
So they, uh, they took the train
to, took a train to Yugoslavia.
They got caught,
they got deported setback.
And instead of getting on the
train and going back to Budapest,
my parents were like, yeah, yeah, we'll go
back. And they got off at the first stop,
you know what I'm saying?
So he took a train in Yugoslavia.
They get caught at the border. The
guy says go back. But they don't,
they got at that first stop after and
then they pay a guys with the guineas.
They find a guy in Yugoslavia, they
can get them to Italy. So they wait,
they wait, they wait, meet this guy.
The guy gets them over to Italy and then
they're in a camp in Italy for about a
year and change until the Catholic
Church and determined camp until,
oh and that the Americans came over to
my parents and I saw you guys were from
Hungary.
Tell us what the Russians are doing.
Cause my dad was in the military
in Hungary and they said, uh,
if you can show me a map of what the base
looks like, he goes, of course, yeah,
here it is. Here's what the Russians
do. This is where there's today. And um,
I think because my dad helped the
Americans and whatever, I don't know,
somehow we got taken to Canada,
we got a pass to Canada.
And a favorite part about that though, I
was born there, she was born in Canada.
And then one day he was just like,
America, I want to go to America.
And then they just drove in.
And my parents, yeah, Noah,
he got sponsorship to work
at a factory in Detroit.
He was still supposed to go back to
Canada, right. And then one day he's like,
fuck that. But that's immigrants.
Does, dude, that's what Joey is
a loophole and you're like,
fuck you.
Mother went to a party
with her younger sister.
My aunt was 13 Rosita and my mother was
about 1516 they went to a party with two
of the three of them brothers.
My
mom was dancing and she lost sight
of the Rosie and she went outside.
She went to rather thing as
some guy was raping my head,
no taxi drivers in my wife.
My mom broke the bottle and stab them
in the back and ripped his back apart.
The guy died the middle of the night,
so they had to get my mother out of Cuba.
So here's my mother,
1516 years old.
In those days you just went through the
fucking airport and she went to Chicago
first. She labored in Miami, went
to Chicago to see your relatives.
They didn't want to, she ended up in New
York. We have no like Hong Kong, New York.
And she stayed with, it caused me for a
few days and it was a fucking nightmare.
And she met a Puerto Rican girl.
They would go eat and they started running
numbers together when they were kids
from neighborhood booky,
even,
they both got together and opened up
like a little back and started making a
little money. But my mother wanted
to go back to Cuban. See are parents.
So she looked back at the
Cuba with [inaudible] mothers,
uh, identification. There was
no passports at that time.
Whatever the fuck they use,
I don't even know what those passports.
So my mother entered Cuba with
the name of Sophia Cecilio,
stayed in Cuba for four fucking had my
sister then had me stay in Cuba with that
fake fucking thing.
And 1966 he came back into the states
as Sophia Cecilio and that name stuck.
So she just went and got a social security
card. She lived the rest of her wife,
like so free as a CELIAC. People
will call us or feel, you know,
what are they calling yourself? Fear.
She goes, just mind your business.
And what was your real name?
Denorah hilarious. Touro Valdez.
I'm allowed that, but she switched
it to fucking Sophie to Cecilia.
But the lab,
when my mother died,
I couldn't collect social security
because my mom didn't work though.
She worked enough quarters
but under a different name.
That's why I want to apply for a passport
because I might get stopped and said,
wait a second. Especially
now, especially with it you,
you've never, you don't go to Canada
and nothing old gods at this point.
I don't want to do that.
Do you do a border Detroit Buffalo,
but I don't go nowhere.
Just in case they do the paperwork.
Next thing you know.
Yeah, I got some families.
There are no dangerous. Even though I got
to pay the fines if I want a passport,
but I really don't want a
passport to be sure I give a fuck.
I'm never going back to the Seattle,
Idaho,
so they want to come down and
get me be my guest. Jesus man.
Unreal be my fucking guests.
The immigration world is a really,
because you have to listen to two
sides of it. That's why you really,
me being an immigrant,
I have natural compassion for anybody.
I, you know, look what's going
on down by the as well. You,
you want your friends to be a part of
that. I mean you, you have lat time,
you know,
this is our blood.
Look what's going on in the
bed as well as same conflicts.
There's some place in Syria they run
away from, you know, I can't imagine,
I can't imagine. And listen, we
have good and bad in every race.
Sorry. You know, there's white people
that are fucking doing anything for you.
And then there's white people
to pay a half really docile.
They're retarded controller. I can
get into a fucking ivy league school.
So you've got to parties and
say my little miseries that USC,
she's a dumb as a box of fucking rocks.
She's dumb as fuck.
But she said, you were say there's
some people were proud of that.
And you know, you look at that
and when I see that, you know,
I feel fucking bad for saying it just
this way. So nobody gets offended.
I feel bad for SPEC.
A little Nigga kids,
a little Chinese kids who worked fucking
hard do a thousand fucking things.
And now somebody cuts and fucking line.
I feel bad for them.
I feel bad for somebody
who really needs those.
Somebody who came from fucking hungry,
she just wants to fucking be an engineer.
You don't remember when
you started comedy,
how you would go back after your first
year and you wanted to do things and it
was frustrating and think
of of immigrants in mind.
There's about what no matter what
and that Japan, China, Vietnam,
they come here and they body American
dream and they just want to get into a
fucking college,
any college and here comes fucking full
house with the fucking husband and may
see in his fucking cut wife and you know
for 15,000 to put her in a room to take
our sats. Let me tell
you something. You take,
you take a course to take your rest a day.
There's a course
and you take it and they, you could take
it. How many times? Two or three year?
I say yes.
Then you pick the highest score.
So for 15,000 you just threw away 15 four.
So they had her in a room with a mentor
that give a bullshit thing is to the um,
the people who did that,
the paid,
they paid for their kids to
get like near perfect scores.
I couldn't even sell it for like,
these are pretty good scores.
They're like make it, what's
the perfect 6,000? Make It 1520.
So now you're pretending that
the kids are fucking not smart,
like genius level, you
know, it was like the,
the boldness and the balls to have to be
it, to take it to that level, you know,
is it to me is like, I dunno. I think
you're going to play it cheat like that.
Smart. How did they cheat the grades?
Oh, sorry, I interrupted you. No, no, no.
I don't know how they treated the
grades. I don't know. I know that they,
there's different, they were,
these were different cheats.
One of them cheated the sat and the act
and then when the learning disability
and that they need, Oh yeah, that was,
that was one of the cheats is that if you
actually do have a learning disability,
you can, you can get like a
solo extra time for the test.
Proctor watches,
they bribed that person to have a solo
room and then that guy corrected all the
answers. The other one,
there was more levels to it.
It was like a real conspiracy where they
were paying coaches and acceptors off
it,
like all kinds of shit.
He was,
see that 1.3 million bribe.
She's doing 20 years. Yeah. There's
nobody who got around. That's 20 years.
That's 10 years nonviolent.
They put you in a house in Pasadena.
You can't have a bag
book no more. It's, it's,
it's, that's what breaks
my heart. Listen, when I,
when I was doing my little scam at
the University of Colorado, yeah,
I was a little,
I was a loser and I wanted a,
I wanted an education and I fucked
around a little bit, but I did the war.
Didn't really want it.
It broke my heart after I got the
felony and I couldn't go back on campus.
It really did.
It would've meant a lot to me.
You know what if I could have got
a half a college degree, something,
but I got to look at you guys
and tell you I'm a criminal.
I've never cheated on a fucking test.
Maybe like in the sixth grade,
I wrote the answers on my
hand, but besides that I did
the fucking work. You know,
I quit high school,
but my senior year had to quit.
There was no mommy and daddy had.
It broke my heart put me in a different
category mentally what it does to your
psyche. It was just horrible.
Where you working senior year,
I know I was doing whatever I had to do
to roll a truck, load a truck, you know,
fucking paint. Yeah. I was trying to do
things, work for a book. He, you know,
but it broke my fucking heart.
That's why when I went to Aspen,
I tried to sign up for those Mike
Glasses and then when I got arrested they
forced me to take my GED
because if you have a GED,
it counts against your sentence.
If you don't have a high school diploma,
you have points. If there's
a point system, do you get,
do you have a job when you got arrested,
did you have a high school diploma?
Are you married? There's all these
points systems. So when I got arrested,
my point system was one and a half.
That automatically puts you in a halfway
house, but it had a four year sentence,
so you only eligible for a
halfway house at the 18 month boy.
So I still had to do six months
to get it down to 18 months.
I had already done two in county,
so that counts for,
so I pretty much got the prison
I was before halfway house. Wow.
Because I had my GED, I was Rhett
working at the time of my arrest.
There's all these different things
that you have to fill out to get you,
you know, when you go to
prison. When you come out.
I actually just signed
the box and been disabled.
You do know that when you go to prison,
you come out of prison.
You claimed disability.
Really? Yeah. Nobody's going
to hire me. Mental disability.
I got 800 a month in a parking spot,
but the rest of your life,
I didn't want to do that.
You know what I mean?
People do that a lot and
they get the food stamps.
Then they get the other rate and they'll
walk out of prison with 1200 a month.
That's all.
There'll be able to remake the rest
of the life of work off the books,
but that's how easy it is.
I know an eight, he's eight.
It was maybe now you got to Piss in a
bottle or whatever. They get welfare.
You could milk it.
Once you got out of prison,
you could say that you are disabled,
but you didn't want that.
That was 30 years old.
Yeah.
I wa I want it to never
have a ceiling over my head.
Like I could never work for a salary.
I was always a salesman.
You know this week we made 16
next week we'll make eight,
but the week after the how I'll
come back with a $2,000 week.
I never wanted the ceiling over my income.
That was very important to me,
but I also knew I didn't
want a day job in. Yeah,
I always knew I didn't want a day job.
I wanted to be able to have a job that
one year I can make 60,000 and the second
year I could make 90 and the third I
could make one 50 because I controlled
myself. Did you, did you go to prison
by the, in Colorado it was, it was,
there was in Colorado,
a place called Canyon city for diagnostic
where they fucking tap into your head.
They see going on in your head and they
do all these testing and then you go to
a certain facility.
Was Your prison cause it was backed.
I don't know if it was the same now is
that, was it all super segregated? Like,
like you hear about now you want me
to whites over here. Latins over here.
It's so weird. It was segregated,
but I broke that segregation.
Really?
You had made the guys that hung out
with me break that segregation like it's
weird that I'm married to a Terry Clark
because my best best friend in prison
was a guy named John
Clark who hated blacks.
Trinks Spanish Jews.
You Hungarians.
He,
he was white power.
But when he hung with me and
hang out with three young pups,
cause I ran with three black dudes
who I loved and gave my life full.
So there was guy that looks
like Josh Parlor was librarian.
He looked just like Josh bought
him. Yeah, he was the librarian.
He was from Buffalo, New York also. Jesus.
Yeah, he shot his wife and the mailman.
Oh, that sounds like a potter then to the
fuck of the tenant to a federal. Yeah.
So our crew was me, him, John Clark,
who was like heavy duty white supremacy,
but not really.
He went between the bikers and the
white guys. He had the tattoos and shit.
Me and him had visitation together
because we both were supervisors in the
kitchen.
So we wouldn't take visitation
on Saturday's and Sunday's
we'd take visitation
when they thesis where I
could eat some pussy. Yeah.
Because then I thought I'd make
my girlfriend at the time show up,
we'll address with no panties on.
You and your wife would be
on the other side of the,
it just be two of us took
visitations on the weekend.
I got to sit next to somebody.
I can't finger my wife or nothing,
but on Mondays and Tuesday I was
slinging Vic eat das, shooting the load,
and then she would bring me
groceries and I go back to my thing.
So me and John Type,
but I was tight with a
guy named Spencer Antwan,
a black dude who fucking,
uh,
sliced the guy up and he
had a really good attorney.
So he had involuntary manslaughter.
He killed him at a party.
He was tight with me. But the best Jude
that was my brother was this guy, Eci,
he was a professional bank robber.
And if I think back about this,
he's the first guy that
talked to me about stand up.
Really like he taught me about throwing
your voice. This is a funny story.
We were talking one that we couldn't do
drugs in that cause they drug test to
yet,
but you could do acid.
So we would do acid meet
at a certain bunker.
Me The two black dudes. And we just
had with John Clark and the librarian,
the librarian was a deep guy.
He liked doing acid and all this shit
and he would talk to you about Venus and
all this stuff. But one day we were
talking and this guy, Eci was his name,
he's like, man, my Mama, I been in
here for too motherfucking long.
It's shit. My freezers are
slipping. I'm like freezer.
And he goes, you my mother
fucker freezes and I don't know,
I don't know what you're talking about.
And he was telling me that when you
go into a bank or liquor store to rob
somebody, when, how you say
freeze is very important.
And it's got to be very like foodies,
like it's gotta be very intimidated
because if you don't say it the right way,
people get kind of fucking tough. You know
what I'm saying? And he goes, one time,
me and my brother went in to rob a bank
and my motherfucking brother had a cold
and shit and he yelled,
freeze.
But his voice cracked and the
motherfucker pulled out a gun and shit.
I had to shoot him in the leg. I
mean, I looked at his police report,
he had shot like 80 people.
This guy,
this guy was a jail 80% of his life,
but he was hollow iron and my freezers
are slipping. So he would tell me, man,
I got to work on my
mother fucking freezes.
I'm getting out of here like six months.
It's shit. I gotta get back to work.
So I go like, so what, what can
I do to help you? And he goes,
let me know when people are gathered
and I could try my shit out on them.
You know what I'm saying? It's like, oh
well we'll start in the cafeteria first.
So he would come in and look at me and
I go and like everybody would be online
and getting that food and there'd be
people sitting here and he would kick the
door down and go freeze motherfuckers
and white people would duck and shit
and he would come up to me.
I told you I got to work on my
motherfucking freezes and shit.
That I would wait on Saturdays when
the black dudes or play dominoes in the
laundry room and they'd be listening.
Fucking who's Whitney Houston's husband,
Bobby Brown. Brown. Don't be cruel.
Like I was in prison with the album came
out and the brothers would be dancing
though, be cruel. And I
would run over the ECI, no,
actually I got like 20 brothers gathered.
He goes,
what the fuck off and go there in the
laundry room and he would watch down there
to the back door and I go in there
and the front be hanging out with the
brothers and all of sudden the door was
kicked open and he'd go freeze and all
the black dudes or duck go,
you black motherfucker.
You almost gave us a heart attack and
that she would put his arm around me and
he'd go, man, if you could scare
Niggas, you could scare anybody.
And I used to go and see you killed me.
And he'd run that drill every fucking
Saturday if white dudes or cook and he
kicked down the door,
freeze and then God dammit you again.
And then he would come up to me.
He's like,
I'm getting my freezers back up if she,
that's one of my favorite stories
I've ever, oh my God. ECI,
I'm working on my freezes.
I'm working on my freezers and shit.
By the way,
you know potter.
Did you know that he can't come where
Josh Potter can you get it up and he kinda
ejaculate with a girl. No. Tremendous.
That's even better. He wants to,
who wants to come?
He wants to,
I want to drill a hole near fucking
eyes and they can't take it no more.
You know what I'm saying?
When you're fucking them and their one
eye balls hanging out and they're like,
are you going to come and get it? Cause
I come quick. Yeah, I come in a minute.
So if I can come in right
there with you brother,
if I could come in 20 minutes and just
keep giving it dick go from puffy,
the asphalt, the mouth back
to your fucking back to,
yeah,
but that's my fantasy.
If I couldn't come for an hour
or hitting you in the face,
making your socket popping it out,
hitting you, you're like confused.
You don't know where you're going.
So He's never come. He's right.
That's how it usually goes. By the way.
That's it. It's an hour of fucking speed,
but he, he can only come up. He jerks off.
Then when you want to come after the
chickens laying there like she got shot in
Vegas. Good. I'm saying like she's
laying there, the one leg is hanging,
you know what I'm saying?
Her mouth was stretched out as asshole.
It's still open like a dragon's mouth.
You know when you fuck him in the ass,
he ass hole stays open and then just lay
that drinking milk trying to recoup and
shit.
You're given them like Gatorade.
Then you just drink off on the tits
and call it a night. There you go, man.
Why are we even trying to solve this dude?
I don't think it's a problem.
It's not a problem. Yeah,
that Joe convinced me.
I mean I want to just mangled three
checks that you couldn't come there.
You can give him each day for an hour.
You can get all through to show
up at once and just keep going.
Like Donna Emily style.
You ever read that book?
You wouldn't work in this town again.
It came out in 98 about a hooker wrote
about her experiences and she wrote about
Donna heavily that she would go to don,
Don Henley with all four bitches and he
would sit there and this table like this
was this table and that's a fireplace.
He would make them, Ben don't, don't,
don't even look at me.
He wouldn't even let them look at them.
Just look towards the
fireplace and bend over,
do lines of coke and then get up,
open up his robe and stick
it in here like four times.
Then he sit back down again.
You can do a couple more lines and
he'd have to be there for eight hours.
This could be your life, Josh. God, I
hope so that someday do it. Like when you,
when I was younger and I did coke,
oh there was dick for fucking four
hours. Yeah. You just give it out deck.
They're looking at you like what is this
gonna stop and then when you do come,
it's one of those long loads. Yeah. You
ever have those loads? Like I used to,
I used to be on probation and there was
a dude that was like a Gi Joe Dude that
failed the police task. But his
assistant was a good looking woman.
Like she was Kinda cute if I was dirty,
she was byte dirty.
Nobody talked to him boldly because she
got like a Woodlake leg was kinda like,
she had like that little limp.
But you could tell the bitch hack game.
Like she could suck her cock.
I would look at the eyes and I
could tell this bitch is deadly.
But nobody talks though because of the
fucking wouldn't like or whatever the
fuck she's got.
You got shot in Vietnam.
I didn't know what happened
to her and she was very nice.
I forget what her name was. I'd
see. I'd always flirt with her.
But when I was doing and I wasn't on,
I figured out how to fuck with
the Piss test among circumcised.
I would take like fucking pool,
clean it and put it on my dick and then
pull the skin over it and put like a tab
over like a bread town, like
a, like a fucking rubber band.
And then when I would go pee,
the guy would watch me and I would take
my thing out and just pee and then pull
the skin back and all the pool cleaner
will go into the fucking thing.
And then that would zap the machine.
They would always say to me,
this mother fuckers up to
something. So he asked her, he goes,
maybe you could see what the
fuck he's doing. So I would,
I knew when I would call and go,
I'll be there at four cause they would
call you and then you had to call it
machine that would tell
you what color was up.
And if the color came up that your,
let's say your color is maroon and
they go to, these colors are green,
Maroon and black.
You have,
I have to call him and tell
him what time you coming in.
You had till five o'clock but you got
to make an appointment. Then she'd tell,
you know, if he adds it, that means he
was a watch you while you're pissed.
But with me,
they hadn't mirrors around me.
They couldn't figure out what I was doing.
So they sent her in.
So before I would go and fucking do a
half a jerk in the car and get my Dick
Nice and big and then I'd
sprinkle it, the fucking, uh,
won't clean their pool cleaner.
I still got scars.
I got little holes in the my Dick
and Draino. I would grind it up,
I would fucking put it under my
Dick and then pull the skin back.
And they would fall into the piss test
and Zap it. But before I would piss,
I would take the hammer out and show
it though. Like what do you think?
What do you think?
There's something nice and she would look
at it and look around the room and not
like I knew I was glad I
ended up asleep or whatever.
A swap and spirit cause I flirt with it.
Nobody talked to the woman
because she got her fucked up leg.
So I'm off probation,
I'm delivering Chinese food.
I'm slinging coke at the same time at the
Chinese restaurant. So I would have to,
I will have you called the Chinese
restaurant and say, I talked to Joe. Yeah.
What's up? Oh you want to
even drop soup, whatever.
The cocaine would be hidden under the
egg drop soup so that if I got in trouble
to train these people got in trouble.
I didn't put it in the bag.
This was when I was out
already out of prison.
When that I knock on the door and who
answers the door, it's her. And she goes,
oh my God, it's so great to see
you. How have you been like, oh,
it's quite to see you,
man.
I gave her a hug and I put
the Chinese down and she goes,
what are you doing with your life?
I got to know them getting divorced,
but I got the standup comedy and I'm
trying to deliver food to make a living.
And she's like, oh that's so sweet
of you. You and her broke up.
Oh you must need a hug.
And as I started hugging and we started
swapping spit and I touched a little
monkey and I could feel nobody had even
touched her monkey like that knee is
themes started coming and I started
fingering that motherfucker like a savage
and spit with her.
And my hand was nice and what?
And I'm finger that I got
a pinky surrounded her
asshole and I'm working with
finally I put it down slowly and I pop
up pants, I take a out,
she got one fucking town
mum fucking slow figuring
out at the same time.
So while I'm fingering,
I take a pants down and I go,
I don't want to see what the other leg is.
So I took the leg off of a good leg and
I left the fucking bad leg carbon cause
I don't want to know one those.
If she's got like a pole on the day,
I one of those fucked up fee.
Let's see.
That's why I picked up a
fucking leg or eat her pussy.
The clit flopping was huge on sucking
like a on like a piece of bubblegum.
I look up and she's like this Christie,
like with her mouth open, I ain't go,
now's the time to put the helmet and
that fucking mouth. So I switched up,
I started to finger
Lucina and I went around.
I put that fucking hammer them out
because she didn't know what it is.
She's like,
well that was that time and at that time
I was trying to fucking live weights
and shit so I wasn't jerking off cause
somebody told me that the jerk off that
your protein,
I was retarded and when I came in
a mob it was one of those loads.
Christine that don't stop.
Yeah. One of those things,
I know you're sucking it with your eyes
closed and then after a minute you open
it up cause you're like,
what is this going to stop?
I like to look at a swallow on it and it
was endless. It was fucking them list.
It was just a loaded deck. It was like
a month and a half and not covered.
There was Valium in there and Xanax.
Hey Joey,
thanks for stopping. I shot a load them
up and when I took my dick as you went.
Okay. It was nice. He drank a gallon
of mountain dew. She looked at me,
she started getting a little dizzy.
I was selling Valium at the time.
I was thinking like a hundred
milligrams of Valium at night.
Well I shot in the mouth with a
religious rants. He was glassy eyed.
She gave me a $3 tip and I
left and I never saw her again.
She was a tech Chinese for the
slept for a week. Oh my God.
Oh you got any dates coming up?
You can still Twitter handle. You can
still feel it. Not felt like I bet it was.
I think it was like a
three minute wait a minute.
You didn't even banger put
it in a regime. No, no.
That's proceed was
tremendous. Yeah. Oh, okay.
I looked her eyes blacked out at
some point. I didn't listen close.
Once I shoved my tongue in your ass,
you black out.
It's like get 40 than Yonkers was too
whack out and let it happen.
What's going to happen anyway?
This is too good. Oh
Man. Take a shower. Uh,
Joey Diaz. Edge of what's
happening now. Oof.
He needs to go to church after that.
You got to see him at the comedy store
going his dates. Where did your web,
your website, I don't know for Joey
d is that in that you're the best.
You're the best. So are you going,
I love you so much Christine.
You lived that load
when I was saying that.
That's why I did not take it
back to college. Like what
time you got a badge yet?
You sat too hot. Yeah, it
was a 40 weekends. Yeah. You
got a bad batch of those.
PLOP. I meet those sperm where
you just kept walking. Swallowing.
This is the worst picnic.
A lot I've ever
chicken come pretty
hungry. Yeah. All right.
Our closing song by a car,
his bites, hard core fund. Um,
uh, Joey Diaz, everybody. I love
you man. I love you guys too.
Bye Bye.
Bye Bye bye.
Retardation,
retardation,
turn,
bye. Bye. Bye. Bye Bye.
Retardation,
retardation,
retard, retard, retard,
retard, retard, retard.
Bye Bye. Bye Bye. Bye. Bye God.
Hi. Thank you for watching that
episode of your mom's house.
Please continue to watch more. You could
see all these were my hands gesturing.
You Click on those and please subscribe
if you have not yet and subscribe button
and then we'll get your money.
Thanks.